Five four,
three,
two,
one
[inaudible] ladies and gentlemen and his brother Mike,
Mike Clarke,
the second man to ever give me paid work ever in my entire professional career.
Opening up for Lenny,
Jay's and Pittsfield,
right?
Yeah,
I remember that one.
The photo Gig,
I don't even know if norms around anymore,
but I remember that keg like it was yesterday.
That guy,
I paid my rent many times.
Many times.
Guy.
And you did too.
Working for you paid.
My roommate I worked for,
I worked for Mike,
one of the craziest gigs I ever did.
I think it was a one and done.
You never did it again.
It was a restaurant and I was in the seating area and the microphone for the
people when they announced their table was tied to the PA system
in the middle of this punchline,
he'd be like,
so I said to the guy,
Clark Party,
party to Clark or tables ready?
Oh No.
Was that,
that wasn't the Mexican place downtown?
No,
I wasn't Mexican place.
Who was a seafood place.
Oh yeah.
I had a lot of one night.
It was back in the day.
Well,
that was the beautiful thing about being a comic and Boston is that if you lived
in Boston,
you could go anywhere within like an hour,
two hours outside the city and work basically every weekend.
It was Tuesday through its shot,
Joe.
Yeah.
We will work seven nights a week at one point.
It was so much,
you know,
and,
and cash,
cash,
cash.
Well it was amazing,
but it was also terrible because a lot of people were very bad with the taxes
and they,
uh,
I always put,
my mother told me,
don't fool around with the taxes or the mob.
You might've been the only guy.
Oh,
I paid,
I pay.
Well,
you might've been the only guy.
Everybody else got hamstring.
Yup.
Knock.
She got killed.
Kenny got killed,
got killed.
And then when they got killed,
it was like hundreds of thousands.
It was because it was years and years and you know,
and you've gotta make that up.
Like,
fuck y'all.
Yeah,
there's no getting out.
It's no good.
Now you wind up paying it for the rest of your life.
It's like student loans or something.
You know,
what are you doing out here?
What's going on?
Uh,
but when came out to do this justice,
no,
this a little bit more,
ah,
I was gonna do Kimmel,
but smells got so smells single mother.
I'd like to fuck it was under show show to show you today's yeah.
And I pled Rocio Tanos love interest and I love,
I love bro Shit.
Rosie a break 35 years ago.
She never forgot it,
you know?
And she was always pretty great to me,
so we were going to do that and then it didn't pan out and they show got
canceled.
So sexual impropriety or something,
it had nothing to do with me.
Oh,
really?
That's why it got canceled.
Evidently.
I don't know.
I someone behind the scenes.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened to be that was the norm.
And now shows get canceled
and now,
oh,
thank God they didn't have cameras.
Cell phones.
I'd still be doing
time.
I forget forever.
You'll get me a demo going down to,
uh,
to do the Navy Seals,
family foundation,
big fundraiser.
We do every year.
I said San Diego.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Not a cornetto at a good party.
Vice Carrie Jackson says navy seal that we golf would one day and we'd been
touched with ever since.
He's,
he's there.
The real bad ass.
Yeah.
Core Nanos that island,
right?
Yes.
I've never been.
Oh yeah.
It's beautiful.
I went down and Mike it due to an obstacle courses sell.
Right.
So I climbed the rope.
That was,
so then there's these logs and they're going to have the logs up there.
I've run a quick,
there was spinning logs that one time,
nearly broke my back.
That was it.
I was out of step on them.
Yep.
Yes.
Running [inaudible]
as you're running across.
So yeah,
it's not easy.
It's not an answer.
You have a mouthpiece.
No.
And not because it seems like
the only ones out there.
Yeah.
Well that core Natto island,
I think that's what Dick Cheney lives.
Oh yeah.
A lot of,
or Donald Rumsfeld.
One of them rich warmonger type dudes.
Yeah.
There's a lot of,
a lot of money out there.
I was sitting rumps sells office at the Pentagon to just cross on.
Well,
no,
but you know,
my buddy who was with me was reading this stuff on his desk because he can,
he's a contractor.
We can read upside down,
you know?
And so really there's God marine.
Whenever realize what he was doing came up governor,
I said,
what did you seek?
It's not good.
It's amazing that those guys are still alive.
Oh yeah.
Especially Cheney.
And he's got somebody else's,
a heart inside of them.
Yeah.
I mean,
in the end he had the person killed for that hat.
That's what I used to do it.
I used to do a bit about it,
how he had an extra secret service agent.
It was only eating like vegetables,
how to jog every day.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Why do I have to do all this stuff?
It's good.
Good.
Everyone.
When Dick has a heart attack,
they open that guy off like a fish was still beating heart out.
Yeah.
He,
he had a pump inside of his body at one point in time where he didn't have a
heartbeat because he had this crazy pumped.
It would just circled the blood,
but there was no,
don't,
don't.
So someone checked his heartbeat,
they would think he's dead.
There was no heartbeat.
Wow.
So he could fake dead.
You could take that in a bad situation.
Monster movie.
Wow.
I had a,
I had the opposite problem I had,
I was doing a show and they made,
you know,
he had to go,
when you do a network show,
they made you have a physical physically.
Yeah.
So I went in and the guy goes,
oh my God.
He goes,
what?
you feel okay?
I feel great.
It's your heart is beating 283 beats a minute.
And I go,
isn't said that like a professional egos.
That's like a dead man.
You Moron.
So he said,
ah,
this is horrible.
283 beats a minute.
Yeah.
Like your po like crazy.
Like we'd go on,
written down.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
what would they stay?
Rushed me to a hospital.
But before they did,
I said,
hey man,
I really need this job.
You know,
if I give you some money,
he goes,
are you trying to bribe me?
I go,
yeah,
we gotta be dead Nigga.
If I don't have this job,
I don't want to live.
I need the job,
you know?
So they rushed me in and then they,
uh,
I ate trivia fibrillation and then it was both sides and I hold the record for
being jumpstarted,
you know,
when they defibrillations Yep.
The mass general.
Yeah.
It's like a phone book.
How many times they're doing it over a hundred.
They restarted you a hundred times.
Yeah.
You see the future.
Are you willing to do the original pitch and show Jesus while they finally,
they finally did the ablation where they go in and they burned the part that's
flapping and they found out the other side was flapping too.
So they,
it was like eight hours on the table had this great doctor,
my friend,
uh,
you know Everlast from the house of Payne?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's got a fake one.
So he takes the microphone and puts it up to his chest and it goes click,
click,
click.
It's got like a fake valve in there.
Well,
I'll titanium val.
It's really creepy.
Wow.
Puts the microphone right there.
I'm hear it.
You can hear it through the mic.
Oh my God.
It was crazy.
I didn't know I was,
it was asymptomatic,
you know,
and I said to the doctor,
I said,
well,
what do you think of is,
you know,
your weight probably has something to do.
I said,
well,
I did a lot of blowing.
Gosh,
you'd have to do credible Amotz employees.
Well,
there's a small mountain,
the Peru mission that much,
Lynn,
I got that much of that,
of that fucking the whole crew.
I mean,
Sweeney and I talked about it when he did the show,
that whole crew,
that nick comedy stopped crew was a coke came or fucking extravaganza.
Oh yeah.
It was very fortunate that I did that.
Didn't still have never did coke.
Oh,
it was Joe Joe.
I don't like don't.
I went to Columbia,
see where it was made.
Yeah.
I was going,
oh my God,
what a wine tour.
Two days to score.
Well,
yeah.
They said we sent it off to America.
Mr Linny.
I go,
there's got to be a new shipment and then I got an ounce of blow for $200 I had
a lot,
I couldn't even finish it in a week,
you know,
but I've tried.
And how much is an ounce of blow?
What does it look like?
You know what I'm Scott face thing.
Know Scott bigger than that.
That's like 28 grams in,
but an ounce of pot is like,
yeah,
yeah.
With that much.
I was at the same thing with coke that were bigger.
Same bigger to me.
I had it everywhere.
Yeah,
I remember the car.
I said,
Lenny,
you have to decide whether it's a coke at me.
I said,
do you want to live for the road?
I know what happened,
but
it was amazing.
I really enjoyed Colombia.
But uh,
did you go there just for coke?
Yeah.
No,
no.
I went back recently,
a couple of years ago,
I went to do a,
uh,
upper notice.
They were filming a movie and,
uh,
they asked me to come down and I went down there and I went,
I remember some of this,
you know,
but I was doing it now,
but saw Spanish.
No,
I had no where to run lines.
When did you stop doing it?
22 years ago.
Wow.
23.
Yeah,
that's a good amount of time.
What had to,
you know,
I was doing this movie and uh,
I've finished the guy,
I had patrolled this guy through a wall and I really liked the guy,
you know,
and,
and I didn't want to hurt him and he said,
no,
you gotta.
So I put him through the wall and took a door off the hinges and he said,
Lenny,
we don't own that though.
This is what he bulges place.
I go,
hey man,
I'm done after today.
You know,
someone's going to pay yet.
So the guy I got,
I finished and I bought a bag of blow and whiskey and the bag of dope and some
beers.
And guys you happy?
Like I said,
yeah,
if you want to get real happy.
I said,
you don't scare me,
so we'll pick up at 6:00 AM.
So I went back to the hotel and met my buddy,
which out to buddy we went out.
He said,
let's see how many bugs we can go to before they charge us for boots,
you know,
to hey,
why don't you,
yeah,
he said it was.
So we ended up at the tall ships down at the fender hall and the guy didn't know
me,
so we paid,
we said,
we'll stay here.
Then he realized who I was and we drank free,
went back and were doing blow in the door,
banks opening week free.
Saudi said,
what did he said the guys,
come on,
we're going to go into like a rave.
And it took me to an AA meeting in South Boston and uh,
it just,
it clicked,
you know,
I thought it was a CAG.
I the blow with me and it's come on once it all lines,
which just listen,
listen,
this is after a bender after.
Why?
During a Penta,
I just don't like it.
Well on me and I thought it was a rave.
I thought we were going great.
Great.
Phil Barrier?
No,
he was my,
he's still my sponsor today.
Wow.
This young kid and you know,
I said,
well you know,
how'd you get nice and did you have a problem?
He says that he's still with the banks with a shotgun.
Everyone on the floor.
I go,
Dad,
you can be my sponsor.
Wow.
This thing Joe,
we got sober together.
Yeah,
I mean died the same day.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Wow.
23 years.
Yeah.
That was the thing about that whole Boston crews.
It,
it was all kind of tied to drugs.
Oh.
And the comedy had that feel to it because the comedy was frantic,
you know,
and there was a thing,
Bang,
Bang.
There was the thing about the guys who came out of Boston,
like still to this day,
they had like the fastest paced,
the most punch marks and the audience is there were used to that.
Any bullshit and it would tell you they would if you weren't good,
you sucked.
And I get off and we would have,
but it was,
there were times when I'd say,
this is going to be new material,
man.
Anyone who doesn't do new material the minute you do anything you've done
before,
get off the stage.
So Raj snippy shit at the back and some you've done that beam,
throw a shot glass with shadow on the wall.
Next it was and it made you come and the people,
the,
like you said,
the audience is that came in there would come every week.
So you'd have to,
and they would not settle for any bullshit,
you know that blows,
that's no good.
Yeah,
there was a,
there was a whole scene.
There wasn't just the comics.
It was like comedy kind of soars.
There was so many people that came to those clubs.
That's shows pull it up,
puts shows that with legendary will the Ding Ho on a Wednesday night,
Lenny would put like 32 acts on [inaudible] of all I'd go,
Lynn,
you know,
we've got to get the show.
Oh shut up.
I got a couple more guys and want to give a break too.
And not have guys going on until two in the morning and a liquor license that
told the cops a couple,
Lenny,
you got,
you got to stop.
And I go have a drink and we'll finish up.
You know,
first the first night he took over when Cremins left,
Cremins was leaving and a Jesus job,
well 85 86 somewhere around there.
I thought it closed at 84 I could be wrong on the,
I don't know,
it was shuttles before my,
I came in 88 you know you're right.
Probably probably around 84 I took over from Barry and she suddenly says to me,
hey man,
batteries leave him.
Will you stay for me?
I'll double your pay.
And I go,
yeah,
all right,
I'll stay.
It's a 15 to $30 right at the time,
you know,
and he says,
you,
you run the club.
I go,
oh no man,
I'm the,
I'll get a guy.
He goes,
cause my little brother,
he just got laid off and pull the right and go,
well what if he screws us?
I said,
if he screws us,
I'll tell my mother will be fine.
So he comes in and the first thing he says to Shoney's I,
the food sucks.
Close the back room close to the restaurant.
We'll get to make that a show room too.
So you'd open the front room,
you go through the kitchen and do a show in the backroom.
Then you'd come back then and wait till it,
and we started,
we were doing six shows a night,
but the first night he comes in,
I was pretty lit up because you're not going on tonight.
You're drunk.
And I go,
fuck you man.
Yo that little brother.
I just got get a fucking job.
Fuck you.
I'll do whatever I want.
Blah Blah Blah.
So he gets Gavin and it go,
come on man,
let's go into cool the [inaudible] cool.
We're doing a lot each and gab cause I'll be right back.
I go out and hey click.
The Fricks locked me.
He was so high.
I said,
you're not going on tonight.
They locked me in the cooler.
And so I said,
I'll show them.
I started fucking drink and everything.
And passed out there to get me out of it.
I can't do it.
I apologize.
Okay.
You were right.
But he turned that into a gold mine.
We'd be doing six shows a night.
Three in the front,
three in the back.
Who Sweeney said to the guy lost it in a gambling.
Yeah.
He just someplace Chinese dominoes over in China town and he didn't pay his food
tax.
And so I guess a year and a half later they came and locked it up.
But first they came and he would send a kid out to a liquor store to buy boots
because they took all the bullets.
So we'd have to buy booze for that night.
And then after that they did came and they took the chairs.
They took the tables.
But yeah,
he lost everything.
But it was Wednesday night.
Lenny,
Thursday night Dj has it Friday night,
Don Galvin,
Saturday night,
Cremins and Sweeney on Sunday night,
they go,
just kill a show.
And what people don't know is that Boston had a different way of doing it.
So if it was the Lenny Clarke show,
Lenny would host the show,
right when he would go on,
you would do like what,
10 15 minutes or something like that.
We're supposed to hit opened would 40 you know why?
You know why I came up with that joke?
That was my idea because yeah,
because it used to be,
you know,
Mitt opening midlife closer and I was always a closing.
I'm going,
hey man,
if I hosted I can do lights and smoke dope in between the guys.
And I said,
well if someone has a bad set and I could pick it up or I can be the buffer
while they get over that guy go.
And it just took off and it was a great way of doing it.
It really was.
And then you would kind of close it too,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know did with different nights,
different crowds too,
like Gav,
like I,
I was always working Wednesdays and I'd be other clubs,
but I was wondering what cab show cause calf had a great show and they didn't
like me.
I was like,
cabs crowd did not go for me.
They hated me and I said,
what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
It was a hole and I had to learn to adapt to different audience.
It goes,
what was the difference between Gavin's crowd that Gav used to say it was more
uh,
they were smart.
Smart.
I mean he was a smart motherfucker.
Oh yeah,
he's got a couple of masters.
Yeah,
he's a genius.
His fucking comedy was so sharp.
He would have punchlines.
You never saw a comment on top of punchlines.
You never saw her.
You are recoverable from the last punchline that he would hit you with another
wall.
Yeah,
it was the first time I saw him.
He came on and I watched him and I said to him after shot,
how long you been doing this?
Because it's my first time.
I mean,
you know,
fucking lying.
Well,
not off to a good start,
right?
Like it was like what competitive.
It was really competitive.
And One night I was doing a show with him at,
some guy came on stage behind me.
He was coming up behind me.
Gav jumped over this railing and escorted the guy off and I said,
and that was pretty cool because I got your back.
And then we drove home to his place,
but it was like three days getting high.
And we've been friends ever since.
But it's funny because he said to me,
he goes,
let me,
I can ask you a question.
He goes,
if you could be
the richest person or the most famous person,
what would it be?
Oh without a doubt.
The most famous.
He goes,
really?
okay,
six weeks later ISCAF I thought about it.
You're right.
I'd rather be the righteous,
the frame shifts but bunch of bullshit.
And he goes,
well I'm glad you came around and see what I mean by smarter.
Yeah,
he's nuts.
If you're the most famous person,
you just going to get stocked every wall.
It's hard though.
It'd be that dude that nobody knows as well.
Cause you know I have five billionaire friends,
billion,
not million.
Billion.
Their friends.
Yeah.
And I think I'm like that,
you know,
their pet pet pet project,
you know.
But I mean,
it's unbelievable.
I mean,
to,
to live like that,
you know,
not show billions they've got,
have you ever seen that?
No.
Never.
So it's,
these guys are just like that more money then you can spend more than you could
spend.
Yeah.
That's a weird life.
And we're like,
where everybody else is struggling,
but no one knows him.
Don't you know?
Well,
some of them people know,
you know,
but these people are like anonymous.
And if money than you could ever,
Jeff,
very clever.
God's,
Oh yeah,
that's,
oh,
that's what I haven't liked that.
Yeah.
And even if you were a comic,
you'd rather just do clubs.
Just show up and do clubs and just do a set.
Once you're on stage telling jokes,
either they laugh or they don't laugh.
If you're funny,
you'll kill.
It doesn't matter if you're famous,
you know,
I would like to,
I wouldn't like to be,
I like doing the,
it is now because it's a different crowd.
You know,
I,
I still do a lot of clubs.
I've worked Mike's club all the time that got for him.
But thank that car for me.
Keeps me open some,
there's some people,
you know how when you work the club,
you get some drunk.
All it takes is one person.
Yeah,
because I still go with the flow.
I mean,
I really wouldn't know what I'm gonna do.
I'm just going to go and I try to keep it,
you know what,
what's happening in the news today and somewhat of Jess Baby,
we're going to go,
oh man,
they break the rhythm,
you know,
and I want to stab him.
You know,
he can't.
Well,
it doesn't always happen though.
That's the thing.
It does happen,
but it doesn't always mean that I need the time.
It's great.
But Len just can't block it out.
You know,
it's,
he's doing it.
No one there locks that are worse than Depaulo.
Oh,
you don't even have to say anything.
You just have a look on your face that he doesn't like what you don't think.
This is funny to whisper in a saw mill.
I'm working with nick with doing some comedy tour up to Rato or some and maybe
autism,
some shit,
all that.
And I was looking at him,
uh,
I was hosting,
I'm looking at him and he,
he,
I think we smoked at the time.
It,
it was a dark,
dingy club and it looked like watch and Lenny Bruce,
it was just like that.
So I'm laughing too.
I step outside the room and this is a pregnant woman goes,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
He,
I really enjoyed you,
but he's going to make me have my paper.
Oh.
But he's so fun.
He's a funny motherfucker and he,
he,
he's been going crazy lately cause the Mueller Mueller report got released and
he said that there was no collusion between Trump and the Russian.
So all of his Twitter,
all of his Instagram was just attack and liberals,
don't you fucking,
why do you care?
Yeah.
You can't retire.
You Lion.
It's just like,
that's so crazy.
Resign.
He's,
he's so crazy.
He put a gun.
He's telling people to put a gun in their mouth.
Isn't that how we got kicked off within the first serious?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You're just telling people to kill them.
So He's,
yeah,
he's doing that now on Twitter.
He's such a fucking animal.
It's always been,
oh hilarious.
He kills me every time.
Brilliant joke.
Right?
Yeah.
He was a guy that made me sink like,
oh,
okay,
you don't have to be like a,
a little skinny guy to do standup.
Cause like he was this big back in the day he was playing football.
Yeah.
He's a handsome guy.
And I was like,
oh,
I had to do was be fine.
Women loved them and he would just shit on them and they love him even more than
Nikki.
Nikki was pretty funny to start,
you know,
I would always have him,
he was having good shows and he just,
he was out at the clubs every night and he just put end.
He was always angry from the beginning,
from the beginning,
I had them on news radio,
we played my brother and you know,
DePaul has always had this attitude that everyone is trying to fuck them over.
Even then I got him this gig and it's almost like he made it happen.
Like,
uh,
it was him and Brian Cowen and Epstein from welcome back.
Kotter will play my brothers.
And on the episode they beat the fuck out of me.
We all beat the fuck out of each other.
Broke bottles over ahead.
Uh,
Brian Count threw me through a window.
And before the thing was cast,
I had told the producer,
I said,
I got this comic.
He's hilarious.
I go,
he looks like he could be my brother,
let,
let's,
let's hire him.
And he was,
yeah,
perfect.
He goes,
can you read so I can see the read.
So he comes in and reads and he goes,
yeah,
he's great.
Perfect.
But the casting agent had different ideas.
She had a friend who she,
yeah,
so she,
she cast this other guy,
unbeknownst that I'd already made a deal with the producer and the show runner.
And so,
uh,
they call nick up and tell them that he didn't get the Gig.
And he's like,
what the fuck?
I didn't get up fucking king.
And I go,
no,
no.
You got the Gig.
It was,
hey,
fucking just told me I don't have to fly
so high.
Make the phone call and find out what happened and you know,
and she's like,
well,
I already hired my friend and go,
you weren't supposed to hire your friend.
Like what are you doing?
Right?
And she's like,
well,
I just,
you know,
I don't know what to do.
I already hired this guy.
Go,
we'll tell him he's fired.
Like this is real simple.
Like the producer wants it,
the network wants him.
And so nick came back and nick got the part and he couldn't believe it.
He was like,
it worked out.
Like he was on the side.
He's like,
you mean the world's not fucking me over.
I go into it and told my friend I wanted you on the shelf.
And it worked out,
but it was like he was convinced he was going to get fucked over.
He got fucked over.
He's like,
I knew it then.
And then he got the Gig and he's like,
what?
What is happening?
Uh Oh,
he's just going up here on the show.
Great.
I love them.
I love that guy.
To death.
You know,
I,
I enjoy one.
You hear stories about people remembering where they came from and they help
people out.
And when I was doing,
I just don't have the Sunday comics had Fox and uh,
it wasn't,
it didn't start out well.
I always wanted to go into,
tend to troops.
But when I got Lenny with CBS,
they said,
no,
yet you have $1 million property and not going anywhere.
So when the troops came home,
I had show it got canceled.
That's a whole nother different story.
I want to talk about that story.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
it's good.
It's interesting.
It's a great story.
So I,
uh,
I go to two 29 pounds marine base.
We pull up in a limo,
we blow anything up,
down and anything doubt up.
And I said,
I'm going to like this place.
So we go into,
in George Lopez and judgmental,
a couple of comics.
So I go up to Jeff Altman and he's the host and I go to shake his head and he
blows me,
hey,
it gives me an a high hat wash away.
And I go,
oh,
what's this?
So they say later in the show,
they said,
listen Jeff,
we have this kid,
I've got a purple heart.
He's back now and we want to unite them with his mother.
And he goes,
that's kind of corny.
And he walks off,
I go,
I'll do it.
And so I go,
hey,
how you doing?
Uh,
police smile.
You know,
Ma,
I missed my family.
Well that's great cause we brought your mother and to be like,
yeah,
hey,
the crowd goes crazy.
And they said,
you want his job?
I said,
yeah,
give me a dollar more than him.
And I took over the Sunday comics at night.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I mean,
and so then they say we go from like a hundred to seven in the ratings and they
said,
what do you want?
I said,
I want you to hide this kid,
Kenny Rogers and his my head writer and get what's you written?
I said,
we wrote me a couple of letters from prison and once a month,
no,
I'm serious.
You told me what I want,
this is what I want.
So they hired them.
And they fly him out.
I pick them up at the airport and we drive to my place in Marina del Rey and he
goes,
which floor with I owe all of them.
You know,
I was living in like a $3 million place at the time.
And he goes,
this is incredible.
So we get jammed up for three days.
The third day he comes down,
he's all bagged up because Lenny,
he goes,
I love you man.
But he goes,
I got a wife,
a kid,
now I can't fuck this up.
I really needed the job.
I said,
okay,
all right,
we'll go to work.
So we drive,
we drive down to Fox and we put,
kept my pocket space at the top of the roof.
It's great.
And we'll go and buy a current affair,
which used to be my report,
which is,
you said you people suck.
You shouldn't even have all these officers and kitty holds water.
I said,
well,
killing him in a radius.
They get all the split.
So we go down and uh,
I said to my secretary,
hold on my,
cause we go in my office and there's three couch.
She said,
why three couches?
I said,
when people come over they might want a nap,
right?
So then they said,
okay,
Mr [inaudible],
they're ready for Kenny.
So I bring Kenny here to meet the producers.
And I said,
just come by the office when you're done.
So 20 minutes later he comes,
person is my office.
You know,
I can't believe it.
You're the fucking boss.
You know what they told me?
My job is to make you happy.
Oh God.
He was great.
Well that show was a great show,
but there was a crazy thing attached to that with your agent that wound up
fucking over.
Not just you,
but a slew of people.
One Guy,
Bob Williams.
Oh boy.
What was it?
Star agencies.
I would a book.
What the fuck was the name?
Like spotlight on?
Yeah.
Oh,
he fucked everybody.
At least Seinfeld too.
But sign,
I don't think Seinfeld and well,
when I popped,
when I get Lenny and I was making all sorts of money,
they should,
you need an agent.
I said I want Seinfeld and Leno's agent,
you know,
and at the same time that he was doing both of them,
so I figured these guys are the biggest guys in the business and he screwed
them,
but they got their money back.
I was like the lowest guy on the totem pole.
So I know I get screwed by $2 million.
Jesus.
I mean,
it was bad.
I remember people were trying to keep you from killing me.
Yeah,
I went,
I found out where his kids went to school and everything,
you know,
but he can't do that.
You know,
you got to let it go.
But it took a long,
whatever it happens.
That guy still in the business country,
he's in country music.
Oh,
they didn't know.
They didn't get the memo
far.
Oh yeah,
it was.
I was,
I was so pissed.
I mean,
because not only did I have the show,
but when I went there,
everything was going good.
And,
uh,
I invited Barry Diller to,
to at Fox,
he was the head of Fox at the time.
I would throw a party for the entire cash,
the crew,
everyone at Fox.
And they all showed up.
And W I showcased a bunch of my friends so they could get jobs.
And Barry Diller goes,
you've really done a great job for us.
I said,
I really love,
you know,
working with you,
Mr. And he said,
okay.
So later in the night this,
uh,
this Asian man came up to me,
he goes,
you know,
everyone likes you but I don't get it.
And I said,
well,
stick around,
hop seeing you,
we'll catch you on.
And I didn't think anything of it.
The next morning I,
they'd give me like a million dollar bonus and they raised my,
uh,
my weekly salary.
I mean,
it was a lot of money.
He was like over 2 million bucks.
And I was going to Dallas to do the tech deck.
Texas state fair would one of the men stasis,
not,
uh,
Earlene or the other one is just some crazy name.
And I landed in Dallas and he calls me,
he says,
I got good news and bad news.
I said,
give me the badness.
He goes,
did you have a problem with a Chinese guy last night?
I said,
no.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I guess so.
I guess.
Well that's Barry Diller's right hand man you had done,
they,
they throw you off the lot.
They said,
I said,
what's the good news here?
We got your money.
And they go,
I want my job.
I said,
let me apologize to the guy.
I didn't mean it.
I didn't know.
And they go,
no,
they've already taken all this stuff out of your office and put it in boxes and
you're done.
And now I do the state fair and I'm going,
man,
this sucks.
You know what I mean?
I want to get back to la to try and salvage,
you know,
the career,
cause I mean,
this is enough that work that I'm the longer welcome at just from one
conversation co I've got stories.
I wish I'd never opened my mouth.
I mean,
I've,
yeah,
no one's as,
as fucked up my life more than myself and unintentional.
So,
uh,
what we're doing,
the state fair and this horse with a buckboard goes out of control and the horse
is swing and a buck.
What's coming towards the reviewing stand?
So I grabbed him,
man dro girls,
and get a ride with,
just as the whole thing is wiped out.
And I'm saying,
did you get that?
Did they get that on tape?
But that was a,
that was the end of my career at Fox.
That was crazy from one conversation where a guy said,
he didn't like you.
How about this?
Um,
but when I'm,
I'm at,
I have Lenny at CBS and it was doing good.
And then the quit the Gulf War came out that,
that,
that killed me.
And then they brought me back and we were hanging on by a thread and they said,
listen,
forget about the show.
We think you're a great actor.
Let's give you a movie deal.
Really?
He says,
yeah,
we're going to give you the first picture,
$2 million.
And then the next picture it'd be uh,
no,
first of all,
a million and then 2 million then to me,
$5 million,
three picture deal.
I'm going to read,
you know,
I can't believe this happened is that one question,
can you act?
And he said,
hey,
I'm making believe I'm having fun with you.
And I get out.
I went,
hey man,
I was only kid and that was,
that was a pretty good get out.
And I,
and I,
I just cost myself fine,
we'll get the homeless but just by being funny and,
and it,
and I said I'll never do that again.
So
like that's going to happen.
Man.
Joke gets better.
I read for this movie true romance,
you know.
Oh yeah.
So I mean I get,
I get clean,
I get straight,
I work on the lines,
I'm ready.
So I go over and it's Ridley Scott or his brother wanted a famous scot directors
and a kid comes out.
I saw how many people in it,
it's 13 cause I was like to know how many even the room,
cause you don't want to go into it.
So I walk in and uh,
and I look at the paper.
He goes,
you ready?
I go,
yeah.
I told a script on the floor.
He goes,
I guess you already said it.
The Times just hitting from the left.
I was hitting frightened.
I said,
you better like it cause you're never going to lick pussy again.
He goes,
Whoa,
whoa.
What does it say?
Look Pussy.
I said,
right in the script he picks up as it says,
the light pussy.
I said,
Oh,
if you like it,
you look it right.
We want to know what breaks out of here.
Get Out,
get out of my office saying,
well,
but that was when,
again,
so I'm driving home and my agent calls me and says,
what did you do to relax?
He said,
you're a brie inactive,
but you've got to get off the drugs.
They said,
I haven't done coke in two weeks.
I was serious for this pot.
Who is he getting it to?
Tom Sizemore liquids.
There's no justice.
That's hilarious guys who were like,
Oh yeah,
up to the neck and cocaine.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh my God,
that's crazy that they get that upset.
I'm having fun.
I'm pretending I'm how I make them believe I'm having fun with you on it.
Just because I thought we were pals half day that given your awkward,
your millions of dollars and they go,
oh,
isn't this nice?
You know,
that's a problem with people that have so much power.
They want you to suck their Dick every second of the day and as soon as there's
any deviation at all,
they think you're,
oh,
you think you're a smart ass.
You're done in this town.
You don't have a lot of power.
You know how guys sleep with women,
you know,
to get hit.
I had a woman told me she wanted to fuck me,
but she was hideous.
It was ignite in them on it.
You know what?
I'm going to Jesus.
I'm not even drunk
trying to back out of it.
Go,
no,
no.
I didn't get that job either.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
there was casting couches for both sides.
There was,
I knew a lady who bang all these like sad little actor guys.
She was always,
she was the casting lady and she'd have these little sad actor guards.
They're all like,
look,
all squeamish and shit.
And you're like,
oh,
look at her.
She's got that guy on a rope too.
And she would bang them all to get these guys party and shit.
Fuck them on.
But she was,
she was aggressive,
but I'm going to add,
it's creeping me out.
Not because I,
I did,
it's not what I want.
The thing is though,
there's no victim there.
No.
Nobody feels sorry for those guys at all.
Not even for a second.
A guy that fucks a lady who was a casting director like,
hey,
he decided to do what he wanted to do.
I was like,
it's such a different thing than a guy being a casting agent that fucks the
actress.
I would fuck a dry cleaner for free dry cleaning.
I'm not,
you know,
it's just a matter of about what,
what do you want to do?
You know how to that not bad at all.
Yeah,
it's a different animal.
It's funny.
Yeah.
But that whole model is out the window now with all this me too stuff.
And after Weinstein got shot down,
I don't act,
I've retired from acting side.
I'd like to see what it's like now and wonder how much different it is,
how much it's changed.
You know,
I've been,
it's changed quite a bit recently,
Joe,
I gave Luhya shot at the club,
you know,
after his heard about that and you know,
Louis called me up and said,
hey,
do you mind if I do a spot?
And I thought about it.
I said,
yeah,
sure,
no problem.
You know,
I like Louis wasn't arrested or convicted of anything and so I put him in,
he did fantastic and Cosby's what do you think I should?
Yeah.
And Ma,
after that evening,
the backlash was just unbelievable.
Yeah.
Just I go,
how long has it up?
What does this guy have to do to try to get his career back then?
Right.
But what is the backlash though?
Because the backlash is not your,
your actual customers,
right.
It was,
they grabbed some female comics slot work and that I'm working for me and it's
said that Mike lock the doors and put a sexual Predator on stage and it was like
everyone there enjoyed Louis and you know,
I'm just trying to help a friend.
He came in and he walked over to me.
I give him a big hug age.
We got no problem.
I got no,
you knit what?
I said I would have called you if that prick.
Right.
He'd give me a number.
He didn't give me an,
he goes,
that's not right,
and I go,
I know.
That's what I told him.
I said,
should I bring him on stage?
She's led you gentleman,
you know this me too thing and everything.
Here's a guy who,
who didn't touch any women,
not in fact,
he touched himself.
That was the problem.
They just happened to be in a room and I said,
you could have jerked off in front of me as long as you didn't get on my shirt,
my shirt.
That's pretty expensive.
I said,
but these,
you gave a job to the people that turned on him.
He gave jobs to and yeah,
there's not,
right.
Well,
there's a lot to that story.
I don't know.
There's a lot to that story that would make him look very different in a lot of
these people that are accusing him.
And one day I think he's going to tell us.
So he,
I had a conversation with him about it.
It's,
it's not as cut and dry as everybody thinks.
Everybody thinks he had power over these women and he pulled his dick out and
start.
No,
there was a lot of,
there was a lot of sex talk and it was a lot of flirting.
There was a lot going on.
It wasn't that simple.
And he's very calm.
He's very contrite about it.
This very,
very,
and he knows he fucked up.
And by the way,
he hadn't done anything like that.
And more than a decade.
It was a long time.
He just,
he's,
yeah,
he's got a kinky thing.
Said I can't,
I can't even,
I can't read chuck off.
If the name is a home,
I'm a wreck.
I make weird faces yelling.
Joe wouldn't be fun for anyone.
I bad guy.
He's a good guy,
no rapist.
He's a sexual predator.
That Jenny Buddy,
he caught the worst part of the wave you.
Oh yeah.
You know like if you're in the ocean and you could be in the ocean on a,
on a fucking surf board and you just catch this little tiny wave and
everything's fine or you could fuck up and be in the right spot when that giant
wave comes and slams you
in the head and you have the same intention and the same person and other and
other times in history,
he would have been fine.
He might,
he would probably be fine today because everything,
everything's kind of,
there's enough of the females that have come out that have been full of shit
like Asia Argento and the girl accused Chris Hardwick and then Chris Hardwick
released all these text messages that showed that she actually cheated on him
and she brought him back and she's just trying to punish him for all this.
But these,
there's a few of those situations now where people realize,
well,
well there's,
there's definitely sexual predators and is definitely bad men and,
but there's also women are taken advantage of this movement and I think the
world is sort of like calm down a little.
Like the Asia Argento thought one was a big one.
You know when she,
it turned out that she was calling Harvey Weinstein a rapist while she was
fucking a 17 year old.
Right.
But she was,
she played his mom in a movie 10 years ago when he was seven.
It's like Jesus Christ.
Like how could you,
how could you have that kind of hypocrisy?
But there's a lot of that in,
in people that are screaming for attention at the front of the line of a lot of
these things.
A lot of them have like dark secrets themselves.
Yeah.
You know,
and like these people that don't want a guy like Louis to have a road
redemption,
they don't want them to work.
Or even a guy like Aziz Ansari,
which is even worse,
he had a bad date with a girl,
right?
Like a bad date.
Where she blew him like three different times and didn't want to keep going.
Well,
wait,
he can't push shit bad date.
That sounds pretty good to me.
It's pretty good.
No,
I,
it's better than no.
Yeah,
but it's,
the whole thing was so crazy.
It's like
there's,
there's more than one side to every story like that.
And to take someone's opinion or someone's perception of something as 100% the
actual event that happened without any other evidence.
It's kind of crazy.
I mean,
I don't think,
I just,
I just think people have to recognize that Louis in particular,
he's been out of work.
He was out of work for 10 months.
He lost all of his shows last time was people think he didn't suffer from that
$30 million to people that think he didn't suffer a crazy,
you're crazy if you think you should never be allowed to work again.
Well,
he's not a criminal.
Right?
He's not in jail.
Right,
right.
So what are you saying?
Like he shouldn't be able to do stand up.
Everyone deserves this.
And that was my point.
Yeah.
I said,
sure.
Louis come in.
You know what?
Yeah,
I want it to give him a fighting chance.
And He,
I guess he is back doing clubs now and he's doing a lot of clubs and uh,
he was very,
that's it.
It's always trying to do,
she's just trying to get his life back.
You know,
he's built in his act again doing clubs and some fucking asshole releases his
whole act on Youtube.
So now all that material has to chuck away.
So he was writing during the time he was gone,
but not performing.
And then he puts together,
you know,
an act that,
look,
you know,
as well as anybody when you have new shit,
it's got some goddamn holes in it right when it comes up.
I'd never written a bit,
ever.
Maybe one or two in my whole career.
That was the,
that was the finished bit when I first did it on stage.
Maybe one
or two ever.
They're always clunky and too,
and sometimes you have ideas.
You're like,
why the fuck don't even try that one.
Like the Parkland shooter bit like w w we,
he was doing that bit right now it's in a very unfortunate bit.
Right.
Especially when people aren't in the club here at and then,
but who knows what that bit would have been if you go with it and tape it.
If you gave him a year to work it out.
Right.
He probably would have figured out a way to make it where it wasn't offensive
and it didn't shit on those kids in the same way.
My best stuff was when she has to go before cell phones and before because I
didn't know,
I just,
I just went up to,
and now what I'm onstage,
I'm constantly thinking,
oh don't go that.
Don't do that.
Don't cross that line because some,
you know,
and that's a terrible feeling for it.
Oh it's horrible.
It's hard.
If the funny shit that you and I have laughed out hard was something that
someone definitely shouldn't have said.
Oh absolutely.
They knew they shouldn't have said it.
That's why they were saying it.
There were saying it to make the audience laugh cause they were like,
I can't believe you fucking said that.
Yeah.
Not like he means like that's his actual thoughts.
There's no maliciousness behind the dye of,
no.
You think I want people to spend 30 40 bucks to go out and that'd be pissed him
off and ruin your night with your wife for a date.
No.
And he end up just trying to make you laugh.
So now it's like,
you know,
it's just so Joe,
I can't remember back with you and Mike McCarthy.
Yeah,
that was like who could work the dirtiest?
You guys would be in the back just dying.
Yeah,
there were nice big Kenny would get heights.
Let's see if we can walk the room and I've seen people suck and have a row,
but I mean women that w we'd love that.
Oh my God.
I remember one night I was feeling great and I said that let me do.
And I was getting fucked up and I turned on the crowd and then I felt bad
because they will show upset.
So discussed with him and these are like regulars usually come.
I started trying to win him back with a bag of,
took me an hour and a half to get them back,
but there was nothing I did.
I show it all ends or whatever.
Said Guy heckle him and I said,
listen,
if you don't shut up,
I'm going to come down and hit puppy right in the fucking face.
And I did.
I went and went up to stage at up this fucking guy waiting.
He was bleeding and the crowd was on his shot.
Hey,
attacking us.
And it took me 45 minutes just to break even,
you know?
And then you kept going after you punched the guy in the face.
That's amazing in and of itself.
God Alando I don't know what I know it was in Atlanta,
it was w w you know,
I'd be stealing a bunch of one night isn't it?
With and I was,
because the crowd was a big crowd,
but it's been like 300 people.
No,
I love Beethoven and this guy just,
and I fucking hate it.
And I would write a,
put the mic down,
Bang went off and he went down.
He was screaming and crying like,
wow.
And I went up in a bipolar.
That's the difference in Boston and Orlando.
Yeah,
it can't do,
you gave me the best
advice anybody ever gave me when I was starting out.
You did right and right after your brother gave me the worst,
right?
True.
Mike told me to work.
Well it was,
it was good advice at the time.
It was smart.
It's just you.
I just said,
Joe May,
I think maybe you should try to clean it up a bit and you know,
and let he comes home and says fuck him.
He goes,
don't let you to have you a great kid.
I love you.
Don't change it thing.
Yeah,
you bumped me up,
man.
Well,
you know what that thing was,
you made me laugh.
You cause I mean,
I've seen everybody.
I didn't want when I started doing comedy,
but 41 years ago,
there was only a hundred comedians,
maybe the whole country.
You don't know what I,
if I heard of someone,
I would fly to their town to go onstage and said,
let's get on Kennison.
You know,
and uh,
you know,
Bill Slayton in San Francisco,
people that dump in Philadelphia,
people I thought were really good in that.
It might,
you know,
I would like to see what it is,
and then became friends with all of them,
you know?
That's awesome.
And then,
then it just blew up.
I mean,
you know,
now you don't even have to have an accurate on youtube or
yeah,
you still have to have an act when you get in front of those live audiences.
Thanks.
So,
yeah,
I've seen it.
I've seen those youtube guys each shit
to draw people out to the club and I for a while,
they'll do it for what you trick people for a little bit,
unless they become good.
I mean,
they keep putting in the work and do the act.
and,
you know,
develop an act,
but you either can do it or you don't.
Like Jerry Seinfeld once said,
very famously that if you're famous,
you have it buys you 30 seconds,
30 seconds in front of a crowd,
they're happy,
you're there,
they'll give you 30 seconds and after that like,
okay,
where's the jokes?
Three.
Hey,
he's a fucking good joke writer.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's still cops smeared off,
still slinging it.
He says comedy store every now and again.
I think he's still in Branson and he has a theater and branch but it comes down
to the store and I worked with him a couple of times.
He's good.
He writes,
he's got new material.
He looks good too.
He's healthy and thin.
Yeah.
But um,
like if those youtube guys,
they have a,
they have a shortcut.
Right.
You know there's there,
they make funny videos on Youtube,
but yeah,
they,
they'll get a crowd even though they're not really funny.
But if they put in the work they can pull it off like it has been done.
The most courageous guy I ever saw was Charlie Murphy.
Yup.
Cause Charlie Murphy was essentially a famous open miker.
Right.
And that fucking guy would,
he started out hosting.
It would be him and dawn now and bill burr.
And they would do these shows together.
And Charlie had never done standup,
but he had the most famous brother ever.
I mean his brother was fucking all Eddie Murphy.
Yeah.
And people saw him on the Chappelle Chappelle show.
Really loved him.
So he became famous and then the guy had balls of fucking steel man.
I did a 22 show tour with him and he had only been doing comedy for two years.
Yeah.
And I had been doing comedy for than 20 and we were co headlining.
So I would headline one night,
he would headline the other night.
And uh,
I mean to be able to go on after a guy has been doing comedy 24 years or
whatever the fuck it was and go on after him and do 40 minutes when you've only
been doing yeah.
And just the balls that got hat and he would just go on out there like he owned
the place.
Yeah.
But passed away,
right.
Chase passed away.
Yeah.
Bought a little over a year ago.
I think all the people that we work with them,
that they're not here anymore.
A lot of them,
I'm gone.
My good God set the ones that suck.
I still there fucking,
hey,
I worked.
You know,
you always make it a point at paypal standard material.
One of the biggest states that Evelyn was,
Ali Jo Predo.
I never met him.
He was this big breath,
big fat redneck guy and what?
Working down south someplace,
maybe Florida and we're in the green room.
Any watch the tonight show and it's on and we're doing the late show and Carson
comes up,
does his monologue and after is my eyelid ship.
All of Joe Painter.
He went out and did,
gosh,
it's a monologue.
This standing ovation.
I've got no one to 11 no,
there was no VCRs back then.
There were no tapes.
They would not that I got,
he's still one of my,
and you stole my joke.
Yeah,
but I do it better.
I got no,
you don't add a it's way to it,
man.
It's off.
Yeah,
but I do it better.
That's what he said.
He's young kids,
young men.
But I do it better.
Well,
you know,
back in the day,
in the Catskills times,
they all stole like there was due,
no honor amongst thieves back then.
And everyone just had jokes.
They were just joke jokes.
Like he almost had like a toolbox.
Like oh I needed three eighths.
And then as television came along and then people started getting in trouble for
stealing,
you know,
Robin got in trouble and a few other guys got in trouble and then it sort of
died off until like,
I mean when youtube came along then it kind of killed it.
There's still a few thieves that are still running around to this day and some
of them are famous,
but most of the audience knows now.
And if you like look at someone who's a thief and then you look at their
Instagram comments like,
Holy Shit,
people go after them and people know now they know.
It's the darkest thing you can do when a guy works or girl works forever on a
bit.
And then you just come along at the finished product,
snatch it and switch a couple words around and pretend,
pretend you came up with it on your own.
When I started,
I was working as a janitor in city hall at Cambridge and I took,
the other is up for bs when we went to the spring fest digital and we saw
Sweeney and we saw Sweeney and Bill Campbell and I'm going,
oh my God.
Sweeney was just,
it was like,
wow,
this guy,
I've never seen anything like it.
And a couple of guys,
a couple of other comics when on my,
the Janice said,
yeah,
funny at and these guys you should do it.
So I talked to George McDonald about it at school the next day and he goes,
yeah man,
you should be a comedian.
I go,
what's that?
He goes,
that's what you saw last night.
So his,
and we listen to woody Allen album and I didn't even know,
I didn't know Woody Allen from Smith.
I had know he was a comedian and he did that joke about hitting a moose up in
Maine.
So I would on,
and I've been onstage before to when I'm at the,
but the thing I was spring frustrates alone and I did this and it was
unbelievable.
It changed.
It was thunderous applause.
Like a stair that automation.
And afterwards this little guy comes into backwards.
Mr Clock,
you're very funny.
But you shouldn't use woody Allen material.
What do you fuck?
You can audio.
Oh man,
the chick.
And that was it.
That was it.
I suck for months.
I said,
but it was all mine.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
There's a lot of guys in the beginning.
That's Greg Fitzsimmons and I used to steal from each other.
We had a deal though,
if he was on it,
cause we both only had like 15 minutes and we had to do a half right.
So I would steal 15 of his,
he'd still 15 a mine and we were best friends.
Oh yeah.
So we'd go there.
He'd go,
oh dude,
that blowjob material killed and fucking Pawtucket.
I said to Kenny,
I said,
Kenny,
that that was fucking patio sets yours.
You fucking morning.
That's where we show.
Cause I had never,
I didn't know what I was doing.
I can't remember his,
I can't remember.
You know what I mean?
I just see all the best guys ideas.
You gotta be waiting for Joey off stage with a notebook and you gotta go.
Say that again.
You had a who used to do that?
Uh,
Mike Donovan.
Mike because Mike Donovan,
I saw him like wow,
this guy.
So just braid real technical about everything.
And I used to take them out after shows and taking the breakfast and he tell me,
he says,
listen,
I'm going to tell you everything you did wrong there no need for me to tell you
what you did right.
Cause you can tell but everything you did wrong.
And he would listen to him and go,
oh my God.
And he helped mold me and he helped make me technically a better [inaudible].
I owe him a lot.
It,
Mike Dunn was great.
He helped me as well.
He told me to record all my sets and told me to get the till tapes did this day
Joe,
he was like,
you never know.
You might say one thing and you forget you say it,
but that one thing might be to make the bit 10 times better Gel.
I listened to him and I taped everything.
There's boxes of shit never last one about,
but I was reading the Lenny Bruce thing and he used to tape,
you know,
and so I didn't realize he was taping the Jack.
I thought he was taping talking to to them.
So you know,
hey man.
So I would write,
when I first started doing it,
I would write for hours and I would go down to kitchens.
Hey Ma,
what do you think it is?
And I tell her check,
she goes,
I don't know,
I guess it's good.
Let me,
I'm like,
she said,
well I really liked that rip tail.
Like a rep deloach
by all the shit right now I rep,
she goes,
that's why Heinz 57 variety,
just get over it.
You know,
I'm the only funny person in the world,
right?
So late.
Oh yeah,
she was,
she didn't take any shit.
So I'm working at the dunes,
what they and Pauly shore.
I'm up by the pool.
And polishes.
Hey Lady,
I took around who is,
he would rip tail,
right?
So,
Ooh,
look at that one.
And he's,
he's,
he's killing me.
And I said,
I said,
Mr [inaudible] was a copy Brit was,
oh yeah.
I said,
awesome.
would you just talk to my mother?
So they bring a phone out to the pool and uh,
Hello Jean.
It's rip Taylor and you hear it.
He's so nice to her,
right.
And then he gives me a function.
I told you he was funny.
Idiot.
I pray.
I ended up doing Hollywood squares.
We've got to be friends with a good guy.
Good guy.
That he made me laugh like,
oh,
he was funny.
He was a hilarious guy.
He was a,
the Hollywood squares me.
He took over that show.
If you saw Hollywood squares and rip Taylor wasn't on,
you're like,
what is rep?
I know.
He's the funny one.
He's the guy you want to hear talk yet.
Donovan told me to record all my sets and he,
you know,
he would,
who explained to you the fuck meter to Oh,
oh,
that was something that young comics to this day don't understand.
First time I ever heard that,
he goes,
well,
you broke the fuck made or I go,
what?
And I didn't even realize I was doing it.
And now what I'm working with guys that I liked that he got,
I said,
you don't listen.
You don't need the fuck.
They dropped the fuck that you don't,
you don't need that.
That jokes fine without it.
You know?
And I mean,
well,
you and I go,
don't,
don't do what I do,
but you can do it when it's necessary.
When it's necessary,
it'll mean more if you don't have 10 other unusual,
well unnecessarily with Mike,
you know,
he,
he tends to use it where he wants to use it and he worries about the guys on,
in front of him,
you know,
he goes,
I don't want you doing it just for the sake of doing it,
you know?
And he was,
you know,
he's,
Mike's a great guy and he's still tapes every show.
Well,
he's a great comic and he's just very aware that you can,
the audience get numb to that word doesn't mean anything,
right.
You don't hear it until he goes up.
And then when he goes up,
you only hear it when it's necessary.
It makes it,
it's a presentation issue because if there's a guy in front of you,
some comics will use the word fuck the same when they use the word.
Um,
they're like,
no,
I fucking like,
and guy with the fucking thing.
He's got his fucking hat on and his fucking shoes are tied in this fucking,
and by the time you say,
and I'm like,
fuck you,
it doesn't mean anything.
I used to open for Leno and he would say to me,
you know,
you're really funny,
but you don't have to be that filter.
You don't have to.
I said,
yeah,
but I,
but I feel like I'm selling out.
Yes,
you're not selling,
you're cashing in.
And My mother always just said,
you can get more work.
And then started doing corporate cakes.
And people said,
listen,
Lenny,
we don't care if you're mildly amusing,
as long as you don't say fuck or anything.
I yeah.
And my flight pay 20,
30 grand and you sign some autographs.
Yah.
So I mean,
so you did sell.
Ah,
yeah.
Those are,
those are tempting.
That's the siren song.
Those was corporate gigs.
Yeah.
Cause I remember,
uh,
like that's like,
that's where Jay made most of his money.
Oh yeah.
I mean he would make hundreds of thousands of dollars.
So he needs it.
Well then someone says,
you know,
he uh,
he never spent any money.
All of his money went to cars and all that money came from gigs.
Yeah.
And he never put out a special,
he had one special on showtime way back in the day in Philly.
Yeah,
that's right.
I remember that.
That was what,
it was good.
It was a good special.
And I talked to him about it.
He goes,
Hey,
wait,
why would I do that?
He goes,
I put on my act,
he goes,
give me just give me $1 million.
He goes,
that's going to cost me money.
But his whole thing was he didn't want to do it because that material was gone
once he did it right,
but he would go to these places and do the same act like two years later and
people be like,
what the fuck?
But he just had this polished.
But all people had said to me,
hey man,
I really don't care for him.
I said,
well what do you,
listen me,
I said,
I used to open from and one that I was at Nick's and I was,
I supposed to do 20 minutes and whatever.
I was hoping for something,
I do my time and get off.
That's just respect.
And he come in and he goes,
well,
I said,
okay.
So at the end anyway,
so now I do about 45 and I stayed there,
all crowds going crazy and I'm walking off in my mind that I'm going to follow
that fucker.
You know what I mean?
He gets on stage but two minutes it was like,
let me who he was that good.
He was amazing.
Don't know.
I don't know.
Cause when he used to go on Letterman back when he was young,
crazy,
dark hair,
he was the edgy calm,
which is hard for young guys to Joe.
He had,
he would do a two hour show and it wasn't too much.
Right.
Know it was killer.
Yeah.
He's extremely underrated as a,
as a contractor.
And I think it's unfortunate that he doesn't have like a great body of work
other than tonight show monologues and people think of him as the guy with
tonight show model.
He's a great standup and anyone that,
that I see that is really through,
I give it up.
You know,
it's,
it is the thing,
you make me laugh.
You know,
I like if you,
if you had successful and it's,
I'm not getting,
I'm gum there,
you know,
that's good for you.
You know?
I mean,
I don't belittle anybody for the success in the same way,
you know,
but,
but if you make me laugh,
then I,
I'll pay,
I'll pay to go see it.
If you don't make me laugh,
it's a waste of time to worry about something you don't like because obviously
other people like it.
What do you give a shit?
Yeah,
I feel the same way about music,
which I don't,
there's a lot of music I don't like.
It's they sold millions of albums.
I don't care.
Yeah,
there's no room.
I just want to,
I just want to laugh if he can make me laugh.
That's why some of the people I hang around with just skill and we'd go out,
we go out to dinner,
everyone puts his cell,
phone's on the table off.
Beautiful.
You know,
cause it's been a nice,
yeah,
we can't be,
all you need is something that would take you down,
you know.
Oh God.
So many people are fucking interested in just looking at their phone all time.
Now,
if I wasn't as old as I am,
if I was a young kid coming up now I'd be an animal cause I wouldn't care.
And it,
oh you can't say that.
Oh,
let me tell you this right now.
And the thing was,
you know,
when I started,
people would say,
oh my God,
what a funny take on it.
And like,
well it's an oh funny tag.
It was what I actually thought.
Right.
Rather than,
you know,
popped up alone and that build on the old.
I just,
Oh yeah.
Cause I,
that's why I've never thought it was funny to anybody.
I just know that I'm sick and I just use that as,
as the under the guise a few miles.
It works.
Yeah.
Know it works well.
We were very lucky that in those days in Boston,
maybe I started in [inaudible] 88 but in,
in those days there was,
I remember in in stream who had you had the comedy at the Charles River up the
theater above downstairs was the connection right over here was nixed by and
over.
There was duck soup.
Right.
I was fucking crazy.
It was fine.
God,
he opened one club.
What was that club in the hotel?
Brad.
What was in the basement?
Jokers.
Okay.
This place would hold over three hours,
dutiful rule.
And One night I had Mike bind that.
C'Mon,
you know Mike and Mike bind it.
I should do,
she's done a documentary right now on the store.
I said,
there's some time I'm in the back it backstage,
don't Lij and he brought to the tie on it.
It's a part of the page where the dress and the dress room years and this is the
other comedians or how to work well.
The other comedians or mom up chop up
Jesus Christ,
the DUPLO watch the edge of people got relax,
relax.
It's just stunt coke.
It's not real,
you know?
So there's no other place like that.
Like the scene in New York was very different.
The scene in New York,
there's the net,
they'd never did the hosting thing.
The way they did it in Boston,
there wasn't as many clubs that were like close together.
They would talk to the crowd.
There were no joke.
We from,
and then there was,
it's a little different now.
Now there's a lot of jokes,
but the,
I think I attribute that to the size of the rooms in New York.
You're on top of people.
That's the first thing I noticed when I moved to New York.
I was like,
God fucking audiences.
It's literally would be like I'd be standing on stage and you would be the front
row.
Everyone's so close because there's no state catch a rising star Dangerfield
there on standup,
New York state,
New York.
You're on top of you.
I used to go down,
I take the train down and stand in line,
wait for number to go on at catch.
And that put me on last cause I was from Boston and I go out when I burned it
down and go,
hey man,
you know,
here's your $10 $10 I'd give it to the pot.
Then I get onto the night owl and go back and I did that for years.
And finally some like bells.
It was good to me and even Pisco gave me a break and some other guys.
But Mike said,
what are you going to nef which went through the window it here,
let's,
why go to New York?
Let's have them come to us.
And w the thing,
I was just like an explosion.
It was,
there was no place like that scene.
And I feel so lucky that I started standup in [inaudible] 88 in Boston.
I feel like I just caught this wave.
No.
Yeah,
it was,
when did you leave Joe 91 I think,
or [inaudible] 92 to go to New York or La,
New York.
I got signed by Jeff Sossman.
Okay.
That's when I moved to New York.
Then that one he was driving limo.
Then when you went to la,
it was that the baseball show you got with hardware.
But Mike Stop.
Yeah.
And the funny thing about Mike's.
Dot.
I always wanted to work with him.
I just,
he's a great guy.
He is a great guy,
but yet he had a ton of incredible body of work.
So we do a movie together,
we to something,
but uh,
up in Canada and we get an a beef,
you and Mike Star.
Yeah,
I see.
yeah,
yeah.
That's it.
So I said,
I don't know.
He said something that we were drinking and we were drinking like Labatt black
ice.
You got the hangover before you get high.
It was done.
Powerful shit.
Right.
And he,
he said something,
he goes,
hey man,
I waited 10 years to work with you.
It depends on like a deck.
And he said something.
I leap over the table.
Fight broke out.
They had a bus?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
I was,
I was on him like a spider monkey.
That was all so,
but I was,
I was like three 50 at the time.
So when I,
well I landed on him.
He went down,
you know,
and they,
they broke it up and they chose out and we're walking out and he goes,
you know,
I'm very disappointed in you just appointed me.
Fuck you.
I'm disappointed you.
I waited all this time to work with and we,
we,
we made up,
but it was never the same.
You know?
What year was that?
Oh Shit.
I don't know.
Long,
long time ago.
Probably 25 years ago.
91 92
oh,
that was probably even before I met him.
Yeah.
I worked with them in [inaudible] 94 yeah.
I saw him last night on a,
on a dumb and dumber.
Yeah,
he's great.
He's a great guy.
Yeah.
He has a nice,
I,
you know how he's drinking,
I yay.
Shit happens,
but you know,
it was per diem.
You know,
my first couple of movies they get per day,
I go,
what's this?
You Go,
well,
this is put their money.
I go,
what's it for while,
you know,
to buy food,
what?
We get fed.
There we go.
Well,
you know what I mean?
So I spent it,
right.
Spend it.
I didn't know you could save it,
spend it.
And I would,
oh,
I was shit faced every day.
It was crazy.
You know?
But it was fun.
Yeah.
Lauren.
You learn.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So I moved to New York and uh,
I think it was either [inaudible] 91 or 92 and then I moved out here in 94 so it
wasn't in New York for a long.
And then you get news radio.
Dot.
Yeah.
I got hardball.
Got canceled.
That was,
yeah.
Terrible show.
But it was on,
what's that?
Fucks.
Yeah,
it was fun to flux is first shows.
I don't think so.
No.
Well married with children and Simpsons and there was a lot of shows on there.
They were doing sitcoms though.
That's,
yeah,
it wasn't very good.
It was a lot of problems with,
it was also an interesting thing to see that the pilot was really funny.
Jim Brewer was in the pilot.
The pilot was great,
but the pilot was made by the creators of the show and then once the network
decided to pick it up,
then they started bringing these network hacks to come in and turn it into some
bullshit fucking show.
And it was terrible.
They rewrote scenes and it was,
it was a disaster.
So I got to see like how really funny writers and really funny actors can put
together a really funny pilot and then that show could turn into dog shit
because of network meddling,
executive
meddling,
and then to go from that to news radio,
which was like the polar opposite that I was just,
they got they bay,
they didn't give Paul Simms much grief at all.
They let him do whatever the fuck you want it because he was coming from Larry
Sanders show and they knew he was brilliant.
And then they had,
you know,
working with Maura Tierney,
Steven or Steven route.
It's taking over this incredible,
incredible.
It was,
it was the luckiest Gig ever.
I couldn't believe it.
You know,
I've been working with those guys.
I never even took acting lessons.
I,
I had a couple acting.
They made me get a coach when I first got a development deal.
And I think I took like four or five lessons with this lady.
I was like,
Hey,
I had,
they'd give me a deal.
And they said,
you've got to take acting lessons.
I went to this acting class and this woman goes,
okay,
we're going to be a tree.
That's what kind of tree?
A big tree.
Willow,
I don't know what,
let's not pay.
Okay.
I,
and this and this.
Same on everyone caught on like ants.
Well,
ants.
I see.
I see a letter to go.
What?
I go,
I don't know why it would be an edge because what fucking movie I gotta be a
giant.
You know,
that's not what I'm looking for.
And I left and I got one two days later and everyone quit the class to like 30
people at the glass.
They all let me get to Sherry's.
They all fucking quit.
It was crazy.
Well,
the problem with the acting classes,
I mean it's good to practice to learn how to read lines,
but it's just pretending that it was,
oh God.
I'm not saying I'm Daniel Day Lewis or I know how to do it.
Like one of those guys.
That's a different level of acting.
That's it.
But if you're on a sitcom,
right,
and if I'm a Sitcom,
I'm playing a guy like me.
Right.
And it's just,
it's just like standup,
but easier.
That's what it felt like.
And munchies,
similar way.
People said,
what?
What's,
what was it different?
So I said,
well,
okay,
the difference between doing a sitcom,
there's a camera and if something goes wrong,
we take it again and a nightclub,
people can throw bottles at you again.
You've got dead.
Oh my God.
What?
I opened for Aerosmith.
Uh Oh Geez.
They used to come and see me at that stitches all the time.
And I had no idea who they are.
When someone said,
you know what that is?
I said,
yes,
I'm Arrowsmith said like one of the biggest rock bands in the world.
They go,
you know,
I was at the disco cause it was the
dance.
You could get laid,
I could dance.
I was up.
I was like,
I was like Travolta.
It said,
how pay by which it was fun.
And that was,
it was crazy.
So they
get stumped that,
so even when I was a fat guy,
I could dance.
I was like Gleason,
you know,
uh,
they come and they said,
we want you to open fresh.
I go,
yeah,
no problem.
So,
Eh,
like wolf to the Orpheum theater,
this is one of their many comebacks.
You don't have to,
but they were still getting high,
I think.
So I go in with the crowd is going in,
you know,
and they're saying,
hey man,
I heard this a comedian tonight,
we're gonna fuck him up and I'm listening to this.
I'm going,
hey man,
I'm the comedian.
That's my,
some guys,
Lenny,
Lenny.
So they call,
what are you doing?
I said,
well I'm going to no,
no,
you go on to stage door.
I didn't even know what to add a stage toy.
So I go back and they're all,
I mean it was fucking wild.
So I go on stage and uh,
they stopped pooling right away and it was like runway lights.
Arrowsmith had decent credible lights.
I couldn't see any and this is but for 38 did throwing bottles and balls,
the smash and all around me.
Right.
And I'm going and then all,
and then he'll dad,
fuck you.
Bang it.
I'm good.
I'm dodging shit.
I can't see it coming right out of this.
I said,
so this kid throws a milk that hits me in the balls,
drops me to my fucking knees and be like damn,
milk not up here.
Yeah,
I think it can be right.
That nuts.
Oh it's Steven Tyler hatches bonding.
I dragged me through the curtain cause I'm right by the curtain.
How?
Cause I'm backing up.
I'm trying to get away.
And so there you go.
How much do we say we go out a couple of grand,
he goes,
here it is.
Come back tomorrow night.
So I'll fuck wait.
So I'll go back to the next night and they go,
fuck the rolling stones,
Aerosmith,
the greater truth until like a rally and you want to go to Japan when I was
like,
oh no.
So you gotta figure a workaround.
Oh,
well you,
you learn.
I think if you're a good comic,
you learn from your mistakes.
If you don't,
you know you're not going to,
you're not going to proceed.
And I did.
I had,
I had the pleasure of working with,
I work with,
uh,
who's pretty woman who switch a gear.
No,
no.
The Guy who sang pretty well.
Oh,
Roy Orbison.
Yeah,
I think that's how bad my mind did.
I so,
um,
and with Kenny were up about three days and I said,
I got to go to Wooster.
I'm open for Roy Orbison.
I'm almost out of gas amount of blow.
I'm exhausted.
I pull into this place and uh,
I go up there and it's this food picking in this whole table,
all this food.
And I hadn't eaten that day,
so I just thought rapping.
I'm like a bear.
So now I fall asleep.
Right.
I kind of
pushed me back.
Well,
I wake up and he's all in black.
He's got those glasses and it's fucking where he says,
you're the comedian.
I said,
yeah.
He goes,
the brilliant watch.
I'll be right back.
So what I do show,
great show.
I come back voice.
You are fantastic man.
We you want to go until I got to get some know you have some blow.
I leave
next.
The next day man,
Roy Orbison asked me to go on the road with them.
You know that,
that work with uh,
Rachel House,
you know?
Wow.
And he was so good to me.
Oh Man.
He goes to London.
You're the funniest comedian I've never seen
then with the Vegas Vegas.
Oh,
he was great.
It was,
it was amazing.
The only prototype I have open for that I really hit it was juice Newton.
She was such a pitch to me,
man.
Yeah.
I was a young guy,
you know when I was doing like a cape cod melody tent,
you know,
and she was like a country star,
right.
She had one song,
she had one head.
I just know what it was.
Yes.
She was made now.
So my buddy showed up,
my on my high school boy climbed up and they took the Jews.
Not when they took the letters and put Lenny.
Yeah.
It didn't work out well.
Is that what she was pissed about or no,
she was just pissed.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
Maybe she didn't want a comedian over.
I Dunno.
You know what I mean?
I was excited about meeting and you know,
she's Stein or choose to do,
but it's a play with that came a heights or some shit.
I didn't know she had one big hit.
Yeah.
A buddy of mine who was in love with her.
Juice.
Newton poster on his wall.
Every time we go over his house,
I'm like,
what the fuck are you telling me?
He wasted his time.
It was a long time ago.
I don't even know who that guy is anymore.
I don't remember his name,
but he was Mike.
But um,
you know who opens up from Metallica is brew Hula.
Yeah.
Tours with them and it apparently he's fucking sensational.
Oh yeah.
Well,
because he's a big Metallica fan and he does a game show and he's so good.
He's great.
I love you're one of the most underrated guys ever.
Really.
He's just so,
he doesn't give a fuck.
No.
And I said he just wants to make a living and have a good time.
You know,
he's not trying to get more famous in the already is,
but he's,
if you get a chance to see Jim Breuer,
holy shit,
he took the white for kids to Africa.
It was talking about the trip to Africa from Metallica.
No,
no,
just,
well,
I think they were there,
but he,
he,
he moved a wife and kids over at the typical water.
I take my kids to Africa,
but they would have gonna have to get malaria shots also.
I don't want it to that.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
It's not only that,
but you know there's,
there's like,
I don't mind the lines and I don't care what is going to fuck my kid.
No,
but wait,
wait,
let me finish.
You got a mosquito with age by chin.
What happened at works?
It don't think that works.
I don't think it works that way.
We got to fight out.
Yeah,
but that was what everybody was worried about law,
so it's not just me,
but in the 80s that was one of the big fears was that mosquitoes,
mosquitoes are going to give,
you know,
one guy would have HIV,
he would get a mosquito bite and they would fly over to you and will give it to
you.
But then I'm sitting like monkey in the tree,
a tree monkey.
They isn't that how the age thinks dotty,
I think this is a,
there's a lot of confusion,
but they think it was probably from a hunter who was hunting a monkey and fuck
the puck.
None of them didn't fuck them and gotten cut himself while he was cleaning the
monkey while he was gutting the monkey.
Because this is a very common thing.
It's,
it sounds disturbing,
but what they call bushmeat bushmeat is basically any kind of meat from any
kinds of things.
They shoot in the woods and they would shoot monkeys deployed,
pushing.
It was a whole different thing to different things
that back when there were bushes,
Korea,
he looks,
he called girls,
you know,
a Bush and people are like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like no one has a Bush anymore.
Oh God,
that's porn porn.
Change the game.
They changed the change.
That's the,
the biggest influence of pornography in American culture is not just that people
watch it,
but it changed the way people groom their pubic hairs.
Oh yeah.
I grew up mine.
I shave.
I might might've cause it makes me feel younger.
Good mood.
Yeah.
Once they get gray,
it's like this pressing.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
you touch that little Nigga,
hey
look,
I'm a kid again.
Yeah.
Bush.
But anyway,
that's how aids apparently they think HIV spread from patient zero was,
uh,
a guy who cut himself while he was cleaning a month.
He was cutting out a monkey.
Well Shay,
it's just an informative show.
I did not at work.
Yeah,
I might be wrong about that.
Look,
I was wrong about the mosquito.
Gosh,
don't be hotter and I just don't think that,
I don't think it's as a is transmittable it's like say a malaria shape,
say mosquito mosquitoes transmit malaria.
Yes.
Right.
Well what's the difference between a good chunk of blood going into,
you know what I mean?
I don't think it works the same way.
I just think it's more difficult to transmit,
which is one of the reasons why men typically don't get it from sex.
They get it from needles.
You know,
women get it from sex cause it got comes inside of you and that's how you get
HIV.
This is a medical talk one on one and PR nation without your donations.
We can't operate.
Send that sound,
but I'll give you a nice handbag.
They gave you a push clippings in his swing.
He's still doing radio.
Does he still do radio?
I need to ask him why he's not doing it once a week I think.
Oh,
there's a little lady that he's not doing it.
He was on Zlx for a couple of years.
It was making some good money to zero radio in Boston anymore.
Well,
there's this case they still kiss and there's parental was the pioneer.
Yeah,
with the comedy hour that really helped boost comedy and he was a big proponent.
He helped.
He helped me an awful lot.
I remember one night he came in and he said,
you know,
he's got to make them move on there.
Hey Man,
I don't want to,
I don't want to smack you around because you know this,
this ain't going away.
He said,
why don't you come on my show?
I said,
I don't know how to do radio.
She's like,
you the best comedian.
I'm the best DJ to work.
I tried it.
We were selling out theaters.
I mean,
it was just incredible.
Every time we'd go on a show,
it promote.
It was,
it was incredible.
And I really,
I really appreciated his help,
you know.
But uh,
is he still around?
No,
he unfortunately passed.
I went to see,
oh,
did,
I went to see him two weeks before he died.
They said Max in the mass general.
So I went in and he started laughing and then nearly choking.
I go,
I said,
man,
what's going on?
And he says,
Oh,
you know,
it's,
it's not good one.
He only got a couple of days,
is it aids?
He said,
no.
I said,
so I kissed him on the forehead and he goes,
hey man,
I love you,
but I got got shit that don't like,
I
thought it was from mosquitoes.
I can't be taking it a shot again.
What happened?
Ah,
I don't know.
You know,
I dunno.
But I guess a lot of things went bad,
you know?
And you know,
is Matty in the morning still around all he,
yeah.
That's crazy.
He was huge back when I was delivering newspapers.
Chill.
He's going to be on the road almost 40 years.
Wow.
And they had a TV show before the radio gig.
I did that.
Yeah.
Not a big guy.
I did that show.
Uh,
well he,
he crossed me much and I,
and across you.
Yeah.
And I flipped out,
I,
I threatened to fight him.
So I went on to sports channel and I said,
I will drop a hundred pounds and fight Maddie Segal for children's cancer.
And then,
uh,
Barry and LH said,
we'll put the chairs,
will donate the chest,
we'll put lounge chairs in the brick and then someone to donate it,
the venue.
And then it got really crazy.
And then Maddie said,
listen,
I'm sorry.
You know,
we were doing an event that his mother passed away from it.
I said,
oh,
how can you know?
All right,
I'm sorry,
I paused.
So we're back to being friends because we have friends a long time.
But then you know,
I mean sometimes people,
you know,
you don't one thing about you that I've always said my se,
cause I liked you before I even knew you were a bad,
I said,
I just thought you were nuts.
I didn't know you were,
you know,
stone cold killer.
But the point is what you have such a way and,
and,
and other friends of mine that are just really,
you know,
dangerous people,
very,
very calm.
You know,
even when people,
you know,
push you to the limit,
which is good.
I wish I did that cause you know,
I've been sued a few times,
you know,
I've learned,
I've learned to keep my hands to myself.
God.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
But I,
but I always,
I always admire that there was,
uh,
an NBA player that I want it to come for the Celtics.
Howard.
He,
I think he's with Charlotte now.
And I'd see guys swam him and he'd just turn and look,
you know,
and like Logan Mankins for the Patriots,
people would smack them in the back and he turned around and just give that look
and then they back away.
I always admired people that could control the madness,
you know what I mean?
Cause I,
I just don't want to let the genie out of the bottle.
No,
I wasn't.
That's when you know things.
Can you think of people die,
go to jail,
make horrible decisions when you're in a rage.
Yeah.
Also,
you gotta be like,
if something does happen,
you gotta be able to stay calm while it's happening.
And then you see where the shots are is when people get frantic and the
adrenaline starts pumping and you start hyperventilating and freaking out.
You don't see things.
You don't,
you don't,
you can't see things that are happening.
It's how people get hurt.
Oh yeah.
You learn how to do that.
When,
when in competition,
right?
Competition.
You can never freak out.
You never can be emotional.
If you're emotional,
you lose all track of what's happening.
You lose your breath,
you get tired quick.
I know you that big adrenaline time.
I have much respect for people that you know,
like MMA and in martial arts,
all that.
I remember in college,
my freshman year of college,
a buddy of mine who was a fighter,
Jimmy foul,
great fighter,
golden gloves champion.
I mean he said,
Lenny,
I think you could be a good fighter.
So he took me to this gym in Springfield and I fought this Nigerian.
He was,
he was mine,
Nigeria nightmare.
He'd only been here.
I was like two 20 he was like in two 35 you know,
we couldn't even barely speak English and we got,
we got in the ring for the first 30 seconds.
I was,
I was so awesome.
But then he hit me with his shot that put me airborne.
I mean,
I was out cold before I hit the mat and I woke up and he was staring down,
please don't get up man.
Please don't get up.
I said,
no problem.
And I realized that that wasn't,
that wasn't going to work for me,
you know.
I mean,
I've had lost the bar room fight,
but probably out of fear and just,
you know,
the fight or flight,
I want a boat that they'd both get get,
let's fight and get out of his fastest.
It's always a bad idea.
Like,
but the thing about bar fights too is like you're not fighting one person.
You know those other dudes around you,
you can't see them.
There's people that hear about it on the phone.
They come over the weight goal.
You want to come out,
oh yeah,
hitting you with bottles.
Well weren't you a bouncer?
It great woods.
Chill.
Yeah.
Mansfield.
It was one of the,
uh,
security people.
And,
uh,
I quit during a Neil young concert because a Neil young,
well,
one of the things that we would do is we would catch people bringing in booze.
Right,
right,
right.
I would always have to check people's bags when they were coming in.
But the other thing that we do is we try to keep order in the lawn.
You know,
great ones has that lawn area.
Well,
one day during a Neil young concert,
they started having bonfires in the middle of the fucking gods are,
and people are lighting fires.
And we had to tell these people to start,
they'd put the fires out.
And I remember I had a good friend,
his name was Larry Jones.
He was,
uh,
the whole,
the whole staff of employees was like,
there was a few guys who was guy named alley cat who ran the [inaudible].
He always wanted to open up a place called libations alley cats,
libations and victuals.
And I remember,
I've always remembered that he wanted to open up a bar.
That was his dream.
But first time I met alley cat,
some guy had a stolen one of the golf carts.
They had a security golf cart,
some drunk kid stole the golf cart and they beat the fuck out of him with walkie
talkies.
I'll never forget that.
I was like,
Jesus,
he's guys aren't planning for that.
And you know,
I might've been getting like 20 bucks an hour.
I don't remember what the fuck it was.
But I remember thinking,
Jesus,
I don't want to get an actual fights here because I was competing at the time.
I was 19 years old.
So that was when I won the US Open and I was,
I was in the height of my competition days and this fight broke out on this lawn
and they were all taekwondo,
black belts,
all like either national champions or state champions.
There's like five or six of us out there and my friend Larry,
who was like the nicest guy in the world,
he was in some sort of a
altercation with his guy and I see him slam this kind of stomach and drop him
and might fuck if Larry's punching people.
This is bad.
So I'd always brought a Hoodie with me because I was a coward.
As soon as the fights break out,
I would put a Hoodie on over my security jacket,
zip it up,
and I'm like,
fuck you.
I'm not fighting for $20 an hour out of your fucking mind.
So I put my hoodie on and I quit.
I walked right out the fucking door with everybody else and I just never,
I didn't collect my check that week.
I was like,
you can keep it.
I'm not dying.
It was brawls.
We're breaking out.
People were kicking people's asses and hitting people with shit and it was fire
everywhere and my,
my preservation instinct kicked in.
I was like,
there's no fucking way.
No Way I'm getting involved in this.
That was my last day on the job.
Did you have a work then perform there?
Yeah.
No,
I never performed that.
I never put them there,
but I got to see a lot of guys.
I got C cosmi performed there.
I saw kittens finish.
I saw Rodney.
This was in the Rodney bathrobe days.
So Rodney was backstage and one of the guys who I worked with saw as hog.
Oh yeah.
So like,
cause he would be fucking full naked underneath his bathrobe and he had a giant
Dick and Dick was hanging out.
I spent hours putting body,
we shot this movie out here,
all the Bali Spock's and he's should come out,
get,
let's go get high.
So we're in this trailer,
we smoke it up and he starts taking his clothes up.
He takes the robot.
But now he's shit him justice.
Come on,
wait,
you haven't seen a man's Dick before?
I go and then not,
not,
no,
not so relaxed.
I can put something over,
you know,
he's,
he gets a fake like,
hey,
happy now we go listen.
He goes,
I want it to be careful with this dope.
This stuff's really shy.
I said,
rod,
Abbott's smoke.
It 30 is,
I'm fine.
He goes,
I'm telling you it it bring you shit at the end.
Just bringing this in and Canoga Shit.
I
the shit and I'm,
oh,
pass.
Calabash is way when I live in,
in Merida and I go with a gamma.
How'd you do it guys?
That got lost.
He goes,
I tried to tell you.
Well the back then they had like California weed today is preposterous.
I mean it's,
it's so strong that some people are having psychotic breaks and people have
breakdowns and losing their mind and going into a mental institution 40 times
stronger than what we used.
And I smoked every day.
I used to,
I used to smoke him workout,
I'd smoke,
I'd ride the bike,
I'd swim,
I love to smoke.
I just got,
I got,
I thought it was more creative when I'm smoking,
you know,
it's just like,
like Collins or linings.
Oh Man,
I got writer's block.
Oh,
I'm okay.
But it was just,
I mean,
yeah,
now they tell me it's,
and now it's legal.
When I did it,
when I did get to hide it.
And where are we about it?
No,
it's everyone.
What's interesting is my wife's friends openly smoked pot now.
Like,
whereas like when I was younger,
like if people found out you smoke pot,
they would look at you like you're some sort of derelict like you were doing.
Yeah.
Like you were a loser.
Like even if you were successful,
even if you were working every day,
even
if you showed up on time,
if you are a pot smoker,
and there was some sort of a that that was his big downfall.
He smoked up Robert Mitchum and Mitch.
Yes.
And I got him.
I met him before he died.
Oh yeah.
His downfall,
blah blah.
Well,
it was,
it was a period when it,
oh,
he said dope smoke.
They don't smoke dope.
It's a gateway drug.
I go,
you don't know what you're talking about.
Once again,
I was wrong.
Well,
everything's a gateway drug if you really want it to be.
Yeah.
You know,
but Rodney A.
Dot.
Dos Days of the bathrobe days,
whereas best days,
it's the a full on.
I don't give a fuck days.
He didn't give a fuck.
He was just Friday,
gave Lenny one of his first big national breaks on the HBO special.
And who was on your special with Lenny Schimmel hitch dice,
a dominant driver,
Carol Lifa,
parish Sobel,
Barry Sobel.
To this day,
one of the best specials ever.
It was,
it was not,
you know,
because we were out here and Rodney was audition and everybody for it and makes
you go ask him.
So I said,
Hey Rodney,
should we take a look at me as a kid?
I've seen people toy.
No,
no,
no.
And he walked away and he turned,
he said,
hey,
if you could be in New York next week,
I'll take a look at.
Mike says,
well Beta.
So we flew back to Boston,
we took the train down and Mike says,
you have any day?
What?
You got to do it?
I go,
Nah.
So I go into the Bot and his bill Hicks at the bar and he said,
hey man,
nice to meet you.
I said,
you know,
I guess it's me and you up for the best spot.
You know,
last spot.
I may the best man win.
We'll have have a drink afterwards.
She goes,
I'm drinking now.
And it goes wrong.
Fucking answer.
I went out,
I punched the fucking phone,
but there's a long ago I was so pissed.
And Ronnie goes,
who wants to go first?
I do.
So I went on and I fucking burnt the top around and he goes,
Jesus Christ,
now you're on the show now.
I said,
it's not my problem,
but I,
but a man shot and he's in the bathroom.
Yeah,
of course.
So we've got to be good friends.
One night we left there and we went up to a tavern on the green.
Okay.
And he said,
well,
he's in a bathrobe.
We don't blow a drank at smoking.
And we'd get out.
We'd go up the doorman or not tonight.
Rod,
you've got some nice people and everything.
Get a job.
You looking at all,
you're welcome.
All the fuck you come on.
So you saw Hicks when he was in his drinking stage?
Yeah,
I only saw him after drinking.
I saw him post drinking.
Yeah,
I saw him at Nick's,
uh,
well the first time I saw him,
I saw him at the connection of summit,
Nixon assignment,
the connection.
Those are the two places.
Yeah.
W we became friends after that.
But I mean it was,
that was,
you know,
I,
I'm just trying to be a good guy.
You know,
it's sometimes it's the competitive juices.
I don't,
not sure what it is.
It comes out.
That was the,
well,
the,
one of the things that comics of today talk about is how it is a different thing
in the community now.
Like the comics community is very supportive.
There's no competitiveness anymore.
Right.
It's not the same because it's not like everybody's
up for a limited amount of slots on like an HBO young comedian.
Special Gosh.
Or Carson does none of that.
In fact,
everybody helps everybody because everybody does everybody's podcast.
Everybody supports everybody.
We worked together on the road together.
It's like,
it's a different vibe.
Oh yeah.
What I was coming up,
it was like that.
It was all cut.
Let's cut.
Dot.
Yeah.
Oh is,
and everybody wanted everybody to bomb after him.
I,
I always felt,
I said,
look,
if one of us makes it,
we kicked the door down for everyone else,
but people were making it ahead of me and it was slamming that door.
Shut up.
You better sleep.
But what I open,
you'll fuck it.
I'm not going away.
And that's why I had to go from La.
I come out here and make no money and Michiko you'd be funny if you are red
tiling.
Okay,
I'll get a red tie.
Oh,
that's so much better.
And she met,
she was great to me.
I mean,
she,
she went,
when I broke through that sir,
right there.
Oh,
I know.
I love it.
So she sits to me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like Leno joke,
joke,
joke.
I go,
isn't that what it's supposed to be?
You know?
And I know.
I Dunno.
I really don't.
I know,
but,
but she said,
you're not going to go away.
I said,
no,
I'm not going to.
Okay,
you're a regular.
I said,
what's that mean?
They get like $25 now that would pay for my pocket,
you know.
So I flew back and forth from Boston and he let me work in everywhere and I'd
make enough money to live out here.
And I did every weekend for eight,
10 months.
But it was so smart that you did that because you were one of the few guys that
left Boston.
Right.
All these brilliant comedian Roger Hodgson and yeah,
the Gab.
Yeah.
Donovan and all these guys don't Tony Box.
Tony V.
Yeah.
There were guys that,
you know,
if they went to Boston and got on stage Jericho,
he's right.
That burned the room.
Dot.
[inaudible]
saw in during the 80s and the early 90 [inaudible] I saw some of the best
standup I ever saw in my life.
What guys would murder.
It's hard to explain it to.
Ya had to,
you had to.
So what will,
you couldn't look the guys in the face.
Yeah.
Rogers and go,
wow,
you really sucked.
Everyone was ruthless.
They were ruthless.
But the,
the level of comedy was so high.
Yeah.
Like on a Saturday night you could see Lenny Sweeney,
Gavin,
Steve Wright,
all on the same show and it was crazy.
And then they would occasionally at Nick's,
Nick's was the biggest culprit in this,
where they would bring in some local,
some national guys.
Skippy,
yeah.
Some things brought in skipped terror family who would sell some tickets,
but then they would set them up and they'd have to follow these kids was foul up
fucking assassin group.
I mean it was,
it was crazy.
It was a a murderer's row.
I have some of the best comics ever.
I remember Richard Lewis came and I love Richard Lewis and I think he's a great
comic,
but he came in and Gav goes,
hey man,
have you seen this Richard Lewis?
I said,
no.
He goes,
watch this special.
So I watched him and I go,
it's going to be cannon fodder.
He goes,
what?
I go,
he goes,
listen,
I'm telling you,
it's a lot different from from filming and being onstage at Nick's.
So we came in,
it was me swinging and Gavin and him.
And so we go on and we burn it down and he goes on and then he goes back to the
hotel 57 and turns on channel four and sees Joyce Kobe work,
butchering him in a review.
And he comes back and he goes,
I can't believe this has happened.
I go,
hey man,
listen,
you're a great guy.
Open.
I said,
we'll take care of it.
He goes,
really?
I said,
yeah,
don't blow him throwing shit out the window.
So you guys were insane.
And six months later,
I do my first movie,
uh,
the wrong guys with him.
And he says,
I never forget what you did in Boston.
He was so nice to me,
you know,
and I was a wreck because I didn't do movies.
Well,
it's a terrible position for a comic like him to be,
because he wasn't that kind of comic.
It was like a guy would pontificate and he had these long pauses and stories and
stories.
Funny.
But yeah,
these people don't,
we don't want fuck joke.
Make us laugh out,
go,
go.
And had to be set up right?
Yeah.
A fee out of like a low key opener.
He would have fun,
which I bet he got most of the time on the ride and not,
not crazy filthy you.
No,
no,
no.
Shut up.
Silly.
Fuck you.
I'll come down.
I'm going to fucking stack.
Well you know it was a very unusual group.
Guys have guys in Boston too,
cause they're all giant dudes like between you and Gavin and Sweeney and knocks.
They're big men.
You know like these are big intimidating men who are doing standup.
Do you remember the dorm had Billy?
Sure.
Big Foot.
He nearly killed me one night.
Right?
Well dormant at Nick's.
Yeah.
So these kids come in and go,
hey man,
he goes,
we're sold out.
He gets $200 goes come with me.
He walks down to the front row it takes for kids from Charlestown screw,
get out and puts those guys die.
Come back next week.
I mean that's how it was.
It was just crazy.
It was insane.
You gotta keep your head down.
Oh young comic or keep your mouth shut and keep your head down.
Don't get on anybody's bad side.
They told him I did.
I was doing it.
The connection and upstairs was a show with trans transvestites.
People dressed up like guys dressed up like women before there was titled as a
drag Queen Show and there was no,
there was no heat.
All the heat was in the,
in the middle room at the connection I got look at,
he's pulling passage going up there and I see some guy singing,
dancing and dredge freezing their asses off rights halftime break before the
next show and Billy comes storming in the back room at the connection.
He goes,
who's Luddy cluck?
And Steve Wright goes,
Oh yeah,
what am I going to with this?
I mean this would bait and they take me down to Knicks and they take me down to
San,
they go,
you know that fucking show you're making.
Do you know that that bag show you made fun of what we're producing at?
You?
Ever say that again?
They'll find you dead in the fucking river.
Do you understand?
Yes,
I do.
That,
should I have to go do the show,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
they were stone cold killers.
He was friends with my buddy,
Joe Lake who is my boxing coach.
And I brought Joe Lake to the show on it and they were buddies together and Joe
Lake was a savage and I'm like,
he's friends with this guy.
He started,
he's in jail animals.
He said he's in jail.
He was I sorry,
sorry.
Sorry.
Maybe.
Maybe it doesn't have a radius.
Maybe it doesn't have to be sure he was innocent.
Y'All ever happened?
He probably had a bad attorney.
Yeah,
it was a bunch of animals then.
And people were literally getting paid in coke.
Oh yeah.
My First Gig down in Florida,
I did a place in Sarasota and it was a great weekend again.
So Sandra Week,
uh,
two grand,
he goes,
how do you want it?
You want it in cash or coke?
And I'm about half and half,
half,
half and coke and yeah,
it was nuts.
Then I got whacked out and with the tap.
But she,
Jackie the joke man,
cause I had met him and he goes,
how did you get him?
Like I really don't know.
I,
it was like the time I was so fucked up back then it was like time travel,
you know,
you could get me blowing booze in a car and I could end up from Sarasota to
tamp.
You look at that on a map.
That's not an easy gig.
That's not an easy trip now.
And I would just show up and it was gps.
There was fucking old wooden bridge and you know,
what are you doing here?
Like I said,
I got bloke come on in and figured out how to get there.
God Christ.
And I remember we used to call when you get a Gig back in the day and then some
of them will be in New Hampshire and some weird fucking lodge.
The Lodge,
ironically I'm doing a lot with night.
This strip is male.
Strippers can know what the high school,
it's a male strip.
Right.
And the door.
And I said,
I'm emceeing,
you know,
and I got to do comedy between,
so I go,
Kathy,
is Kathy O'malley here?
Your kid fell down and hurt his head.
Fuck,
you show a Chicago.
Oh,
well we get the directions.
It would just,
you'd have to write them down on illegal.
Right.
Let's write down and take a ride at the fork,
you know,
and then you go two miles and this road.
Yeah,
right.
It's in,
it's in,
it's in Salem.
You'll find it.
That's what they'd say.
So small when you get there.
One night he had me work in Rhode Island,
Massachusetts and New Hampshire.
Three gigs.
And I go in a night.
That's a lot of fucking driving.
He says,
you get though it don't want me.
And I mean,
I know how I did what up,
you know,
get killed or killing someone if it's a crazy Rhode Island was always fun.
And then would Kennison w w w when I first met Kennison out at the store,
I said,
oh my God.
It was like a revel.
I'd never seen anything.
And I've seen everybody,
right.
I said,
this is so I call him,
you got to see this fucking guy.
He's nuts,
man.
It's unbelievable.
He's like this preacher.
What does comedy,
that's insane.
And so,
uh,
we bring them to Boston and my mix is the first star fight.
I had to fire him after the first show.
Why he,
he showed up all fucked up and you know,
I got him some blow and he went on stage and he just,
he was doing like new material and I said,
Sam,
is there any way you could do your HBO?
He goes,
no,
Bro,
that's been done.
That's been done.
And I go,
well,
I gotta let you go.
He goes,
I figured that.
Then they got him a Gig at the connection,
then he got fired from there.
Then you had him a place in Malden.
You get five,
he shows up at stitches at my gig and he comes walking in and like,
oh,
Sandman I,
I can't lose this cake.
This is my,
this is my big money gig.
Do the,
trust me.
Do you trust the bees?
Did trust the bees bring me,
I say,
Ladies and gentlemen,
you know,
you saw him on the HBO Saturday night live is one of the best I've ever seen.
Sam [inaudible],
he come stumbling out,
what half a bottle.
I'm away chugs it down burps and says someone's fucking meet tonight.
And from then on he just found out the room.
Dot.
And by the end of the night,
they had hired him to come back to do the back room at the paradise and it was
off and running.
But Oh my God,
this is like 86 yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So we're in New York and with doing Caroline's right.
And I mean everybody was,
everybody comes out to see the show.
It's unbelief and they're going to do a rolling stone.
He's on the cover of rolling stone and he's supposed to do the today show.
And so he,
he flies in every girl that's ever broke up with them and puts them all up in
the same hotel,
different floors.
Oh my God,
you missed that.
Crazy.
So I had told a story more than the small group of people,
but we're in the room and I'm lying on this side of the bed,
brought his bill,
his mom's dead.
Samsung patched up the chair.
We've been gone for days and Samhsa money goes,
Lenny,
you've got to get Sam up.
It's got to today's show and I the today show.
That's huge,
man.
We can't pull this up.
And he was just at the point where he didn't care anymore.
I thought,
so,
uh,
I said,
Sam,
get up,
get up.
You got into it.
She mother wants you to do it.
This is big.
It's great for your career.
And we turn on the TV and he's putting on his fucking money.
He's put on a scope and this challenge,
it takes off.
And we also,
we watch,
it explodes.
He goes,
I will days high fucking,
well,
there's the,
everyone packed a bag
and his mother's just got,
Oh,
then the phone rings.
This today show we won't be using Sam today.
Oh my God,
I will.
He goes,
you know,
he goes,
that was a horrible,
I think that happened and lose all those assets.
But you know,
I guess she was a teacher,
you know,
I forget her name and he goes,
and the kids were in the classroom and they'll watch it.
Anyone want some cookie?
This cake,
this cake.
I'm right after it.
I mean,
you know,
but he was,
he was fearless.
Phyllis.
Yeah,
he was,
I don't know if you know the story about him,
but his brother Bill wrote that book,
brother Sam and he talked about how Sam got hit by a car when he was a little
kid.
He was a normal kid and he gets this horrible head injury and then all of a
sudden was fearless.
Like that happened.
Roseanne and that happened to him.
Same exact story,
hit by a car.
I didn't know.
One personality changes.
A 100% becomes a totally different personality and becomes his wild,
reckless person.
Uh,
having a bolt of them.
Listen,
you know,
all these Elisa,
these documentaries about him and stuff.
And I see people that were on the peripheral edges.
I mean,
I was with him for a few years.
I mean pregnant with the bar.
We brought up to Boston when he wasn't making a lot of money and might pay him.
And He loved it and we became real good friends and it was,
uh,
it was just a time in life that I never saw anything like that.
What do you break into the preacher thing with his little feet dancing.
So one night we're up,
he started canceling missing cakes and he missed the University of Arizona.
And uh,
his manager goes and he had to pick time mansion and they had just got,
um,
you know,
the cover of rolling stone and all that stuff.
And he goes,
let me,
you've got to get him to the show.
We're open it for him.
I said,
okay.
So Sam goes,
come out,
we'll go back to the place,
but doing massive amounts of blowing shit and I'm getting up to go to the
bathroom.
He's never gets up to go to the bathroom because I smashed up with when Tampa
and we're doing the show.
It was the year that Tampa lost every game,
that professional football team and they came in and some big offensive linemen
pick us guys ever say,
can we meet Sammy?
We've got Sam,
these guys want to meet.
And one of them breaks out,
a little bloats have it goes,
blows away and it,
Whoa,
it takes out a bag,
puts it down and not doing a rush.
You push and walks up and they're looking at him like,
yeah,
he's not human.
We go back to his place and now it's three in the morning.
It's four and a monitor.
It was supposed to take a seven o'clock flight.
And I said,
yeah,
but not going to make that flight is eight o'clock flight.
It's only an hour out of,
you know,
La to Arizona.
That right.
So,
so 10 o'clock the,
the uh,
manager shows up and let me go say,
hey man,
this is not good.
This is a makeup show you,
you didn't show and makeup showed it's sold out.
Yeah.
He goes,
take Lenny wigeon and I'll be,
I'll follow up.
So we're in the,
we're in the plane and he says,
how much time he got done.
He said,
well,
how much do you need?
He goes,
well,
you know,
until he gets it.
So I go on,
I'm supposed to do 20 I'm,
I'm at about 54 and I'm going,
man,
I'm running and I'm holding them off.
Your Sam seven.
I hold them all and I look over and he's on an oxygen tank with a mass.
It was the big Cody's premium that dad live that dead lab premium.
I bring him on and the place goes crazy.
Crazy,
crazy,
crazy.
At afterwards we'd go to some Strip club,
right?
And so we're in it.
Everyone's wild,
man.
He's a pig sty.
You know what I mean?
People can't pollute it.
So I sit in,
all the strippers come over and he's throwing money around and someone throws a
can of beer and he goes,
that's it.
He goes,
you guys want to make more money in a night?
Then you're making a month to come with me.
And we got about eight of them come and we get in a limo and we go back to the
hotel and we're up though.
Tell me,
well,
magic trick I me.
And he goes,
Lenny.
He goes,
I know you're married.
but in about five minutes,
things are going to change.
You might want to go.
He says,
because once you open this door,
you'll never be able to close it again.
And I thought,
my s all right brother.
Okay.
And so I left and went back to my room,
get back an extra cookie from the doubletree room and my room.
So the next morning I get up and I go over to the room and I opened it up and
it's fucking destroyed in this blood.
Everyone sitting around crying,
Sam,
oh,
it was,
I,
I don't know what the fuck this.
So I try to get a cab,
I go to the airport and I fly back.
And till this day I never know what happened.
There was one guy magic.
I mean,
if you ever listen to his magic,
fine,
because I want to know what,
but it looked like it looked like a bomb when of shit was broken.
All of them.
I mean like I trashed my place,
but like dangerously trashed and,
and blood and still still blow Leptin and oh,
it was,
I don't know what happened at night.
You know,
Mark Marin was hanging out with him back in the day when mark was a doorman at
the comedy store and he was a young kid.
Yeah.
He did so much coke with Kinison that he heard voices for a year.
His head was broken.
He heard voices in his head for a fucking year and that's when he sobered up.
He came to Boston right after that.
That's when I met him.
I met Martin and 88 when he had just,
just was trying to get his brain back online.
Right?
Yeah.
He was fried,
cooked his brain.
It was just up for days.
Oh,
not many people could run on its side shut.
We're,
we're in Boston and we,
I think we do stitches and we closed.
I said,
come on.
We'll go over to Lansdowne street cause buddy Vassar's running that.
So now we're drinking bottles of champagne like it's gone.
I said,
that's it.
It's enough.
We got to go.
So we leave.
A champ goes,
where are we going now?
I Dunno man.
It's this.
There's no bars open.
It's after two.
He goes,
you got to know a place.
I go,
most of the place,
I know that they're folded up,
they've been shut down.
He goes,
wait a minute.
the limbo.
We had the,
and I'd had booze is,
yeah,
call the limo.
So they call it a limit when it comes fully stocked.
I goes,
never underestimate my Bali.
Drinking is bad.
It Brad,
that shallow shit happened that middle.
I mean it just,
it was insane.
Just not human.
He's a wild motherfucker.
He changed comedy.
He really did.
Oh,
oh,
he changed what comedy was it?
It became something like before him,
it was people telling jokes,
but he was so outrageous.
And when he did that HBO special,
that one that he did from the Roxy on sunset,
obviously.
Yeah.
That fucking special changed.
Common.
Like it changed people's idea.
Like when he did that joke about the homosexual necrophilia sex on my way to
heaven.
So
I bet there's still one night I go in and the cops,
the cops left Sam and it was like about seven squad cars out in front of the
competition.
Go Sam,
you go.
And there were all aligned.
The wallet,
the steps involved them.
I watch him and he's bombing,
you know,
I mean,
yeah,
it's you.
People don't seem to like me.
I don't want it to be fair.
I have,
I'm at,
you know,
when you go home tonight,
I want you to take a piece of paper,
a Napkin,
something,
anything.
And I want you to write on it.
Someone in your life that's passed,
you know,
a brother,
a sister,
a mother to sacred dead.
I want you to take that home and I want you to get home and I want you to Ypo.
Fuck
so fucking fun.
And ever who he would,
he would leave like 20 or 30 tickets for the cops in that town wherever we were.
And Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
the cops would always show up.
Oh,
that's awesome.
I,
the one night we were up at Mitsis and he's up there jamming with Eric Clapton,
Phil Collins,
I forget who the other guy was,
and then Rhonda boy,
and he's got the cottage and walking it out,
right?
And I'm going,
I can't play,
but on Monday she's in shame.
And so the cops come,
he goes,
let me take care of it.
So I grew up in is like three,
four cars.
The lights go and I go,
what's up?
I said,
hey,
you got to cut it down.
I said,
Oh man,
young can believe it.
Eric Clapton Zine.
Anyway,
Phil Collins and the Jama Salmon exam,
can we meet psychonautic go Sam the cops.
It's okay,
but you've got to come up and take a picture with him and you fuck I should Sam.
I said,
Gee,
dad ended up closing it down.
So he goes up and they have pulled away.
That's when they had the Polaroid cameras and they took,
Paul had me taking the Polaroids and Sam and the cops.
It was what,
what?
I'd love to see those pictures,
but it was,
you never know who going to come over there.
You never know who it was going to come over.
It was just incredible.
He's the example that I always give to comics.
Have A,
a guy who was at one point in time,
one of the best ever.
Oh yeah.
But then dropped off hard,
like he dropped off in a big way.
Just stop writing too much partying.
His brother talked about it in the book.
He just,
it's what can happen.
Like can't you got to respect this fucking thing.
And he was just all about the ride.
And then also he became very,
very famous.
Probably two famous,
right.
You know.
Well we,
we were doing the outlaws of comedy at the dunes.
That's how long ago.
And uh,
he had driven out to Mayo to my Iowa Suki.
I got a call early in the morning,
Lenny,
Lenny come quick.
Sam Tate.
Like what?
So I go over to the Caesar's palace.
They that'd be,
and I can't wake.
We kept my took take the champagne thing,
take it out and pour water on below and smile pushed me out away and she goes,
welcome to Japan,
Mr. Bond,
whatever.
Say That you've never seen it every morning.
Two Mile.
I mean,
she was so funny,
man.
You know,
she was,
I really enjoyed her.
She was sweet.
I worked with,
used to work with at the store a lot.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know if she's,
is she still doing comedy?
I don't know.
I haven't seen her.
She,
oh,
she did this.
She came up,
you know,
and your country.
You say,
I work miles to school in the snow in my country.
You drop atomic bomb on us.
Crazy shit.
Yeah.
Funny,
funny bunny stuff,
man.
But he was,
oh,
first time I ever did ecstasy was they were close into the club that he started
at in Austin,
Texas.
I guess we're all going raw laugh.
Stop.
Yeah,
we're all going.
So,
uh,
he,
he drove,
I think he drove it.
I flew down and met him and someone comes in and says,
hey man,
you got to try this.
It was what is ecstasy goes,
yeah man,
give me,
give me all your guns.
How much I liked about,
give me all you got.
So we got,
we're all on ecstasy.
I never did ECZEMA.
And we're sitting on a couch with drag him into a Obama and he starts to float
away.
Right.
So I mean there's a,
so I reach over and didn't bring him down.
I said,
well that's what the fuck you quit touching Sam.
And I only show it Sam cause thank you Lenny from pretty bad.
Crazy.
And she,
yeah,
he says Christ.
Yeah.
I was in my shitty apartment in new Rochelle,
New York when I was listen to MTV news.
And they told me that,
you know,
on the television,
it told us that,
uh,
he died.
Oh,
they called me,
said Leonie,
Sam's Dad.
And I said,
have you seen the body?
You know,
cause I couldn't believe it.
Kill him by a 19 year old truck driver who was a fan of his.
I could,
I,
you know,
I seen so much and it's a much with him.
I just,
I didn't think he was capable of dying,
you know.
Oh,
wouldn't he still went back to school.
It's just come out and we'll go into set and we go and see she rod and he's in
the robe.
He goes,
Hey Ronnie,
I do.
He said,
what's up kicks you want to be in the picture?
And I said,
well listen Rodney,
I said,
I appreciate but which you put my wife into pictures.
Stemies you'll put your broad and the pictures that I've been on the road with
Sam for the last month,
he goes,
no problem.
Pitchers in the picture.
So we put my first wife in back to school.
She's got a nice prominent role in that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Crazy.
God Damn.
How the fuck did you come out and all that?
So healthy like you look great.
Thank you.
Really do what?
He got my dreams,
your mouth there.
But that,
that's,
that's fantastic.
But you know,
it's funny cause I listened to you,
uh,
about,
you know,
your work.
I take it you're hanging thing.
We just hang,
you know,
people doing pull ups and stuff just to hang.
It's great for your shoulders.
It's great.
It's great for everything.
But 30 seconds to a minute and stuff like that.
And when I uh,
I did,
I forgot I was doing a TV show and I saw myself,
I was 388 pounds or 56 inch ways and I had always been,
you know me,
what about when I first thought it was the thin kid and everything again?
And I just,
I,
I was the only guy I know he did coke at an,
at an eating disorder.
I would,
I would do a line and have a steak.
I just,
it was something about,
it was,
it coke affected me really different than most people.
So I uh,
I had at the heart problems had all that stuff.
I get,
I got,
I started to get better and then I,
I,
once I get sold by attorney,
even water,
food I a bigger and bigger and bigger.
And then one day I just said,
I'm going to stop.
And then I started,
I went to weight watchers,
you know,
and I lost like a hundred pounds with them and I thought it was going to be the
spokesman.
And they ended up giving the job to Charles Barkley.
And then he was talking about fat pitches in San Antonio.
There's a lot of jobs partly,
but I was the guy,
I mean,
and he put the wet,
I lost a hundred pounds with them and I was so deep and it all took off.
And I thought,
I'm definitely,
cause I did Oprah.
I mean I didn't fuck right.
Did her show.
And I thought that she would like me.
That never happened.
So I started working on in my own.
I started riding a bike and I started swimming and I started lifting weights
because they never lifted in high school.
I was always rail thin.
I was like [inaudible] 78 pounds in high school.
And then I start getting into,
I can get to doing sit ups in abs and crunches and,
and then,
well remember when I met you on the,
but it was a movie.
Here comes the boom.
You said what happened?
You know,
and I just in the lifting is,
was from my brain,
you know,
I mean,
I,
I'd go to the gym and it was good for my head,
you know,
and I really liked because I wasn't doing it to look and I was doing it to save
my life.
And then I started like how I look and I started working at it and it's,
it's,
it's part of my thing now and I,
you know,
I'm 65 years old,
kids in the gym,
see me,
how old are you?
I'm 82 you got a six pack medical.
Yeah,
you can have a toe just,
you know,
eat right.
But it's just amazing that you went from wild party in constant just drugs and
booze and partying to 100% healthy.
Lifting weights on wouldn't be here if he hadn't stopped.
But it's a hard trend.
That's a hard turn.
That's a big right angle.
Like,
well,
the kid,
the kid feel bad.
I told you the young,
the bank robber kid was my sponsor.
He,
he,
he's,
he said,
listen,
you can get this together.
You can change your life,
you can,
you know,
the sky's the limit.
And he won't leave me alone.
He cut the last week,
we've got,
well we've got to meet,
I went to one yesterday,
go,
she needed another one.
Can't stay clean on yesterday.
Shower.
They probably crazy yesterday.
Shout about that.
So,
and he just,
he just was,
he was all over me and,
and I started to get spiritual,
you know,
and,
and did you ever,
no,
no.
I'm amazed though.
No,
I am definitely afraid and I'm not,
and I'm not a,
I'm not a preacher.
You know,
I don't,
I don't talk about it,
you know,
I mean,
I'm talking about now because you asked me,
but you know,
and I don't judge anybody,
you know,
a fuck.
I'll drive you.
Well,
I'll drive.
You know,
people say if you,
if you break out when you come to my house,
and I was,
I was insane and I didn't even meet to be,
I didn't know.
You know what I mean?
And now a lot of this stuff's like,
like,
like you were saying,
you know,
punch 20 times,
40 times stronger.
I'm going
to miss any of it.
Oh,
I missed it.
I was not,
but you know,
I,
I can't,
I can't go.
I know how bad I was,
you know,
and I'm an and I,
and I lost,
I lost a lot,
you know,
I mean,
I'm still working,
you know what I mean?
And you know,
I mean,
it's,
it's something I don't want to go back to.
I did it,
you know,
I mean,
I used to go to play by mission.
It was a playboy mansion all the time.
They were the high that would have had seven girlfriends,
you know,
he came up and having a good time.
Lineal,
what am I being goes by?
This woman was,
his old one was putting a coat on and I went over and helped her to coach.
Got You.
Nice.
He said what you want me to,
it was,
let me see.
My son was named money.
It really is.
What do you do?
I'm a comedian.
My son was a comedian.
I go,
you're not Sally mine.
She goes,
yes,
it's Sally and me became best of friends.
But she went comics mom,
Lenny Bruce,
his mom.
Yeah.
And she said,
come get me.
And like,
you know,
horrible story.
I hadn't,
we would get together twice a week,
you know what I mean?
I just,
which I certainly Maya Kim and she,
you know,
Lenny would stay a lot of my fucking material.
I'd go to a club and Kennedy says,
Hey man,
there was a guy in there,
all your materials,
his name Lenny.
He's my fucking son.
That deep and prep,
you know,
she was really funny.
She was a comma.
She was a Co.
Yeah,
Joan Rivers was doing a movie.
Her life.
Sally Ma,
you know,
I never saw it,
but I had no idea her son would steal her act.
Yeah,
yeah.
Great.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
She was at 83 she was raped by some crazy Mexican and broke into a house that,
and I ran and she goes,
I'm 83 I'm by small fat little juice in.
This guy's fucking me and I'm going that,
that Shit Dick.
That's all you've got.
You know,
and she says,
daddy started beating me.
I go,
no,
you cock sucker.
You,
you're not,
you don't have enough of a god.
Are you gonna feed me?
I'm an old woman.
And she would,
oh,
it was all fucking medical Fisher in the hospital.
It was,
it was horrible.
You know what I mean?
It should happen.
You know,
I remember Sam had her open up his special.
Yeah.
And,
and we did the thing to raise money for it too,
you know,
cause I mean,
yeah,
one of his specials,
she,
she actually,
she came out with him,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I had to Sam to her,
cause I had met her at,
at uh,
you know,
I,
she was the whole point at the playboy mansion.
She was still on the old woman and have loved it.
And she would go up there
and it announced an edge.
We'd sit down,
we'd eat,
and then I drove.
I drove her everywhere,
you know?
Yeah.
Pretty crazy.
When,
I mean,
I would,
have you seen that new TV show,
the Marvelous Mrs. Mason though?
Everyone tells me it's a great show.
It's a great fucking show.
I mean it's not historically accurate,
like the way they talk.
It's like they're doing kind of modern stand up,
but they're doing modern stand up back in those days.
And the woman that didn't exist,
like there was no woman like Mrs Maizel historically I get took a long time
before me.
She was more rowdy than Lenny Bruce was in the television show.
But it shows you what it was like back when people were just getting arrested
for saying things.
Right.
And it makes you realize like Lenny Bruce,
that fucking guy paid,
he paid the price and we're all benefiting from him.
Well you know,
when,
when I first started,
uh,
there was one book,
the last laugh that was otherwise about gambling.
It was in the movies.
No,
no documentaries,
anything.
And I wanted to know as much as I could about all the guys who came before me,
you know,
cause I've watched,
I remember I shot Alan King to stand up on our TV and I'm like,
Oh man,
it was unbelievable.
H chief,
fantastic.
Then I shot him is an act of him and he's amazing.
And I get to work with red buttons,
you know what I mean?
I mean he,
he wasn't committee,
but it was really funny,
you know,
and I mean the people that,
that came before me,
I knew every single one of them.
I studied them anyway.
And this was before youtube and stuff.
I just read whatever I could find on them.
And it was,
I would tell these young kids coming up,
I go,
yeah,
I look at the guys who came before you and they're not interested at all.
You know,
I,
when I saw a Gleason Gleason was what I wanted to be.
I just thought Jackie Gleason was just amazing,
you know,
and I,
I want to be like that guy,
you know?
Cause he was incredible and it was,
people didn't realize he was a stand up,
you know,
I didn't even know Gleason did stand.
Oh yeah.
Really one night,
two ton.
Tony Polenta was giving him shit and the boxer and Gleason heckled them and
totally not them out.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
it was,
it was incredible.
You know,
cause I met Art Carney,
you know,
Jackie Gleason was obsessed with Ufos.
Did you know that?
No,
but I,
I kinda dig it too,
man.
That's a story.
This,
this guy told it to me.
Some guy was or,
or a rock band dude.
He told me the story,
and I don't know if it's true,
but the story was that Gleason was friends with Nixon and Nixon said,
do you want to see some shit?
Nixon took him to worry of 51.
It was,
I don't think it was area 51,
I think it was hanger 18,
which is in the air force base and I think it was outside of Columbus,
Ohio.
And they supposedly had some fucking crashed UFO there and Gleason built a
replica of it or how to wrap a club that bill in his fucking backyard in New
York.
Wow.
Homestead air force base
outside of Miami.
It says,
oh wow.
There you go.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Yeah,
I got a bullshit version of it will pull up the,
um,
the actual version.
Where are you getting this from?
I just Google it.
I mean,
it's a cup.
It's a rumored story.
So I don't know.
That's how I got,
I got it from a guy in a band might be bullshit,
but he gave me some book on Ufos and he was telling me about this.
And,
but the Jackie Gleason apparent who was obsessed with Ufo.
Yes.
Well,
I,
I believe this.
There's gotta be something out there.
I don't w w we're it.
I mean that's it.
No,
I don't believe we're ever,
I did a lot of,
uh,
Uso shows and I've been around the world then,
and I was,
every time I've done,
I was in,
off the coast of Turkey someplace in the commander based took me out for dinner
afterwards and I got drunk.
I got a pretty truck.
I was so busy with am I going pretty deck?
And I said,
hey man,
he goes,
let me ask you about,
uh,
area 51.
He goes,
he got stone soul because this conversation never happened.
And he left.
And I had to take a cab to find my way back to a new page that,
that no one knows about it.
Right.
So then we're,
uh,
I'm in,
I'm at the dunes,
this how long ago that was and I'm with these guys who are in the air force and
they said,
man,
we really like to show with Fangio was,
and I got him drunk,
I should say,
man,
what about uh,
area 51?
And they said,
Mr Goodnight.
And they walked away.
So now me and Mike,
uh,
golf and with these blue angels and he goes,
you're going to ask them?
I go,
no.
The second year we golf with them again.
I go,
I fellas tell me about every 50 1:00 AM well,
he goes,
I was flying a plane and I had malfunctioning high land there and they came out
and they pretty much blind fault to me.
It took me into a building and they fixed my jet within 35 minutes and then put
it back to them and say,
you wouldn't never here.
And I went,
oh my God.
So I don't know what's out there.
Yeah,
but was,
here's the thing,
that was an area where they were testing all sorts of military equipment.
They were testing different new,
that's where the beat two or the stealth bomber,
they were testing that there and and the,
and the spy plane,
they were testing a lot of shit.
Yeah.
So there was a lot of top secret stuff there didn't necessarily have be dealing
with.
I understand that and I'm hoping that the risk,
but he's,
but I will try to find out,
but I'd love to go to a man.
Oh Man.
But you can't even drive if you drive up there Joe.
But the time you get your camera out there,
they're on tell you what you get out of here,
we'll lock you up.
You know,
it's,
it's not good.
So they don't even go there anymore.
They've moved to a new area.
They've actually,
because it's so heavily scrutinized because of Google earth and all sorts of
different ways you can see things.
They've actually moved to another area I read,
I read everything I could find about that too.
And I think,
I think I read the book Area 51 cup two years ago and basically at the end of
the book it was like Hitler had these,
you know,
his experimented with the Jews and cut,
put their arms on different ways and had a,
had an aircraft that was looked like a spaceship and it crashed and he's,
people came up with them crazy arms,
but there are aliens and that,
that was in the book,
you know,
so I can shut the shit out.
I know the Hitler d did experiment with some sort of disc type air vehicle.
Yeah,
they did.
I don't know if they ever got it off the ground or what the deal was,
but um,
the most interesting stories,
the story of Robert Lasar,
Bob Lasar,
who was a guy who worked at area 51 and he got fired because his wife was
cheating on him and they were a recording all of his phone calls and taping all
of these conversations.
And they found out that his wife was cheating on him.
They thought that he was going to be emotionally unstable.
And so they didn't tell him why they just released him.
So then he brings friends to watch these,
what he said was we're alien crafts that they were experimenting with and they
were flying these things around that had some,
it's super advanced propulsion system that they were asking him to help back
engineer.
And he brought friends,
do that.
And then they got arrested for doing that.
And when he did that,
then he started talking about it.
So He's been discredited by a bunch of people.
But I don't know who's telling the truth.
He says that,
you know,
they uh,
they wiped his,
uh,
college record so that no one,
but people said they went to school with them and he definitely did work for the
government.
But under what capacity,
who knows?
But his story is fascinating and you know,
I want it to be true.
You hear it.
You'll want it to be
Joe.
They used to fly the team of people that worked at area 51 from Burbank.
Yeah.
Every day.
Fly Him in,
they'd work and then fly back.
Like they didn't stay over.
Well there was at one airport outside of Vegas,
so it was right outside like the,
where the Riviera was.
Yeah.
You can actually look out and see the airport and they would fly them,
the people from there.
And then mark jet.
Yeah.
I want it to be sure.
Of course.
Yeah.
You want it to be true.
We flew up,
we,
we did Guantanamo Bay and,
Oh wow.
You didn't stand up there.
Yeah.
The fuck is that.
It was amazing.
I was like Colin Quinn,
Greg Giraldo,
uh,
who's the little kid on billions,
Mike Birbiglia and Gaffigan,
Jim Gaffigan and someone else.
I know.
We flew in like a CIA play and we did the show.
She's a striker.
Yeah.
It was pretty,
pretty amazing.
And uh,
I tailored my show to the marines that were there and he's a young guy and
during the week they said,
Mrs. Cochran really lifted the morale of everyone is just a,
what do you want to do?
I said,
I want to go over and taught you the presidents,
you know,
not actually to touch scream with them
all.
We can't have that,
you know,
I did.
But anyway,
we do the show and we'll leave in like three days later and I get to the airport
first one day and I see this little HC to plane and I go,
uh,
to,
to Spanish.
Bigger guys go Ponyo nobody,
nobody.
So I go into the gift shop and I buy a giant,
like a water thing so I can,
I can piss in it.
And the guy shop who wants Biz.
So funny.
That's great.
Yeah.
We got on a plane and we fly.
It only took us like an hour to fly in.
This was a four hour flight in an eight,
a two engine HCD over water the whole way and about 15 minutes or hey man,
where's the bathroom?
You have no bond.
You know what?
By the time we hit Miami,
these guys,
well person at the top of the stairs,
it was so fun.
Yeah.
I was in favor then,
but it was,
uh,
it was tangible.
Bay was amazing.
That's gotta be very weird.
It was in that place.
What year was this?
Oh Shit,
it's post nine 11,
obviously.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I said to them,
I said,
well,
can,
can we ride horses and no more horses.
They had horseback riding.
They had beautiful beaches for our troops.
That was,
and I could see sailfish breaking.
And I said,
can we go fishing?
You know,
I've never caught,
no,
we can't.
We can't go out.
And they said,
we'll give you a ride and a gun boat.
I want an a gun boat.
And I said,
what do you think?
Is it my wife boats faster?
You know,
you'll be honest with you.
It was a nice,
but my white book champs.
So then the golf,
he had a carry your mat and hit off the mat.
It's all been run into disrepair,
but it's still beautiful.
And because I did TV and movies,
I was like a gs 13 and I got the best apartment overlooking the bay.
And that bay is so big,
you can fit an entire battle fleet with the,
uh,
with the battleship and,
destroys everything that goes with it,
right in the bay and all it was in,
it was like a robot.
I mean,
the tanks are gone and so they should,
you want to go ride the fence?
I said,
yeah.
Yeah.
So we'd get up in the tower and I see,
I get the binoculars,
I see just Cuban gag.
So I give him the finger.
We go,
no,
what's,
the clock is not an international incident.
And the guys comes out of you guys.
I'm sorry.
Sorry,
I didn't mean it didn't go.
We got it.
I said,
well,
why were you so nervous?
He goes,
this millions of Cubans here,
they could overwhelm us.
And I go,
really?
well,
why don't we have no,
we have a skeleton for us now that if they want it to overtake,
I said,
we could call it an air strike.
I don't would that take and to go about 20 minutes,
you know,
they'd Jetson Camada wherever they could totally out of Florida.
So they,
I said,
they're commander goes,
if you do anything you want,
I said,
I'd like to go into Havana mean by some tough guys,
you know,
take the sheet.
The Guy said,
some bitch come in my office,
we go in and there's a map.
He goes,
see this this way?
You are.
He goes,
that's where Havana,
Cuba is the biggest island in the Caribbean.
I had no 736 miles from Havana.
He said,
you were closer to end and when you went in Miami.
And I went,
Whoa,
God.
Yeah,
I didn't know that,
you know,
but,
but the guys were great.
It was a,
it was a great show.
They put her on TV,
like,
I forget what's spot,
man.
Youtube someplace sucked.
They wouldn't let you go fishing.
Oh,
it sucks.
I want to,
I want it to ride a horse.
I wanted to ride the tankers.
You see all the tank tracks from when it went up over the mountains,
you know,
and they had taken the,
uh,
the prisoners and they taken from,
Camp X-ray to Camp Delta because can't batch was basically like dog cages.
And CNN came down,
look,
I what trading is pip.
I mean over there overlooking the fact that they blew up the world trade center,
but you know,
so now they're in,
they ever,
they're better quarters then some of the marines that have gotten them out of
the supposedly and still do have a lot of innocent people in there.
There was a lot of people that they just scooped up in the wide net of looking
to find people that were complicit or people that were working with isis or al
Qaeda.
I mean,
I wasn't able to grab them,
but you know,
but there was some bad guys.
It's too,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a real bad guy.
When,
when,
uh,
Obama released the five guys to,
for that one guy deserve.
It does.
Yeah.
It,
uh,
one of my buddies into sales is long.
I put three of those guys in there and that,
the bad guys,
it shouldn't be let out.
You know,
who knows?
I mean,
yeah.
It's got to be strange though to be in.
That doesn't mean that is like one of the most famous prisons in the world.
And you're doing stand up there.
Oh it was,
it was unbelievable.
I mean,
which I really liked it.
Uh,
Castro has never cashed a check.
It's 5,000 a year.
We pay him 5,000 here for that,
the Guantanamo Bay and he never cashed a check.
Hey cause she figured if he didn't cash it and we could get support,
he could get out of the deal.
But that was the deal made like what fit and Joe,
it was so,
it was so beautiful.
Like they used to have fire pits and,
and um,
uh,
beautiful things to shade the,
you know,
the families and the beaches.
A pristine,
but a lot of go to hell.
Yeah.
That's so strange.
Lenny Clarke,
you've lived a fucking amazing life,
man.
Oh well I'm going to write a book as soon as a few more people die.
You Brianna equation.
Fuck.
Thank you brother.
Hey Joe.
Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
Thanks Mike.
And thanks for taking care of me when I was up in common.
Man,
you're the best at that.
Paid a lot of my bills because you my friend.
Thank you for sharing.
All right,
everybody.
That's it.
Goodnight.
Wow.
No,
dead.